I'm talking when you can just you know critical thing right?
Alrighty y'all check this out. So I was just poking through the ThreatLocker website trying
to figure out what of all the amazing features they have I was going to talk to you about today.
And the one I landed on was elevation control. Okay, check this out. So ThreatLocker has this
feature that allows you to decide what users can run what programs at what permission level,
right? So if you've got a user, a dev maybe that needs to run a specific program as local admin,
you can allow just that program to run as local admin, you don't have to give them a local admin
account anymore, which greatly increases your attack surface for an attacker. So this is a
great tool if people would use this, I think a lot less people would get Mimi Katz. And I think this
would really increase the security posture of the organization. All right, cool. So check it out
elevation control with ThreatLocker. Let's go back to the show. Sup, Hackers, it's time for the best
episode of the year, the yearly roll up episode where we look back on all the amazing moments
across all 52 episodes of 2024. And we picked the best moments and we conglomerate them into one big
episode. Now, that may sound like a walk in the park. But when you're actually producing it, it's
pretty freaking hard, you have to go back and listen to all of the 52 episodes from this year, you got to
pick the best moments from them and put them all together. And that is a lot of work on our production
team on Richard, on me, on Christian, and, and so we actually recruited some help from the community this
time to get all that work done. And I just wanted to give them some shout outs real quick for going
back listening to some of the episodes and picking out the best moments for us to review. So those
people are Marflap, XSS doctor, Monke, syndrome imposter, Bebex, server inspector, Tharunet, Golden,
PJ stew, Art sec, Inns, and Wizzare. So thank you guys so much for helping with that. Really appreciate it.
I think we've got some awesome segments coming up in this episode. And I personally, I really enjoyed
going back and kind of reflecting on the year really shows how much awesome content we've had on
CTBB. And it was really hard to pick the best segments. But these are the 10 best segments, we
did cut it down a little bit this year. Last year was a three hour episode. And we made it a little bit
shorter this time around. But hopefully we still grabbed the best moments across all the episodes.
And we're going to go ahead and do them in inverse episode order. So we're going to start with the
oldest ones and move towards the newest ones. And hope you guys enjoyed as much as I did putting it
all together because we've really had some great moments in 2024. So thank you all the community for
continuing to support the podcast continuing to make it possible via the discord subs and everything.
And then also, you know, we are launching the full time hunters guild this past week. So if any of you
guys are full time hunters, which I know many of you are, then you're definitely going to want to
check that out ctv.show.ft for full time. You're eligible if you are a full time hunter aka 50% or
more of your income comes from bug bounty, or if you make over 100k you're doing it part time. And then
you know, you apply and then here's one of the misconceptions, then we may approve or not approve you
because there are some some people that do it 50% or more of their time that have very little to show
for the results. And we're trying to build a really high quality community here, committed to
accountability, keeping each other performant, staying on top of our goals, collaborating, and
getting some help from our support staff that we'll have dedicated to this guild. So that's the kind of
vision for it apply if you're interested, we'll get you some more information. Okay, let's jump right into the
cuts from 2024. First one on the list is an episode with with Nahamsek none other than Ben himself.
And he's dropping some great tips on his blind XSS methodology. And there's just some there's just
some great moments in this one. I think you guys will enjoy it. Let's go.
Blind XSS is just the same as your regular stored XSS, I want to say. A lot of times it's stored more than
reflected. But the difference is instead of it happening on the front app that you see, it happens on the
backend where the company's team sees it. So think about if HackerOne had a back portal, for example,
where you can see your reports, the other cost-tack scripting payload that doesn't fire in the report
section, but it fires in HackerOne's backend. Funny enough, if we look up, I actually had that happen
to HackerOne once. No way.
While I was working there. Oh my gosh, that's amazing.
It had a business that says fire off an internal network at HackerOne.
But yeah, it's just a lot of it is you just learn that these companies make mistakes. The mistakes
don't happen in the front end a lot of times. It happens in the backend because they go, well, no one's
going to ever see this and we don't have to worry about it. And guess what? It does happen a lot more than
you can expect.
And so that exact rationale was what I wanted to talk to you about. How do you identify what pieces of
information are going to end up in an admin panel somewhere? Where do you get those ideas?
I think it's very, I want to say, I don't want to say it's common sense, but it's just very like,
it's a thing that you think a company wants to collect on you. Right?
Yeah.
So when you register, what matters to that? That's your name, your email address, your address,
your credit card information in some cases, anything that could identify you as a duplicate
account, for example, like they could say these are the same user. So that could be your browser
information, for example, and things like that. And then things that could also traces you, like when you
have different websites and things like that. Right? It's how do they identify you as a user and you as a
browser or, you know, not the user itself, but like the, the browser, for example, or the device,
they would say the device.
Device.
So those are the things that I look at. Right? Those are the things that I always assume companies
are collecting on you. But then also it goes, the information that you put in to the company. So let's
talk about, let's say like Spotify, for example, you guys post your podcast on there, the description,
the guest, the name of the, you know, you guys, and those are also for sure they collect, but they
could, you know, people probably find those XSS early on and these are those programs, but they don't
think about like, oh, I wonder if this fires here, is it going to also fire in the backend? And if it does,
how do I get them to fire on that backend? Right? Those are the things that you have to figure out. You have to
assume how do I go from A to B? Your A is I have XSS on the core app. How do I get to fire on the
backend? How do I get this engineer, the support person without social engineering,
naturally go click on it.
Okay. So that's, that's where I was going next with that was like, okay, so we've got
information, we put it in, we're using a blind XSS payload that we can get a callback from.
How do we, how are we going to be the one user that the support agent clicks on or the, you know,
backend analytics admin clicks on?
I'm laughing because I don't want to, I don't know how to say this.
Tell me, man.
Tell me.
I know.
I know what you're going to say here.
Joel, what do you think I'm going to say? I want to tell you what you think.
Oh my gosh.
We can cut this out if we need to.
No, go for it.
Go for it.
You just, you open a support chat and you say, hey, I'm having an issue with this thing.
And you send it a link and they click it.
That is, that is, that is also, that's a very good approach, but no, the, I, I don't want to promote
committing fraud. I want to start with that.
Yeah.
But fraud detection is a big part of technology.
How do you get, what's the easiest way to get banned on a platform?
Right?
Like what's the easiest way?
What is the easiest way for them to be like, holy crap, who is this guy?
What do we do? What do we do to get rid of this person?
Right? That is the number one step.
It's either fraud or too much traffic, things like, hey, look at me, like screaming, like ban me.
Number one step is get banned.
That's the first step.
Like how do I get them to go ban me?
Right?
This could be me reporting my own account with like 20 other accounts, for example.
Oh my gosh.
I can just do that.
Right?
Yeah.
So what Joel said is it's, it's to, first of all, please don't go and hassle, support people.
Please don't do that to be real.
But listen, but there's a difference between saying, hey, I have a problem.
It's a legitimate problem that causes an issue versus going like, hey, click on this thing.
I'm never asking the support stuff to click on a link, but I am using the site like an actual
like user.
And I go, hey, I can't find this information.
Where do I find it?
And I go, oh, I still can't find it.
I really can sometimes.
Because guess what?
My page is broken.
Like I have a script tag and that's broken.
I'm not lying to them.
So I asked them like, hey, could you set that information for me?
That's, it's a lightweight social engineering, but I try to avoid as much as I can.
A lot of times, a lot of these blind access that I'm getting nowadays isn't the support
staff being included.
It's me figuring out these companies, how their processes work and what does it happen
to get them to look into something I do?
Whether it's like, you know, I put my credit card number in there, but the last digit is wrong.
A lot of times with, um, when you order something online, for example, they process that manually.
They check for your order manually sometimes, especially for your brand user.
That's been one of the biggest things, dude.
The number one thing that I used to do a couple of years ago was every single time,
uh, John Botterini and I were sitting at, um, in a hotel one day.
I love John.
I look at him, I go, John, you want to make a thousand bucks today?
And he goes, what do you mean?
I go, let's make an order on this side.
I'm like, I'm banned, but I bet you if you put this on this website with a blind context
scripting in the address, the second address line, I promise you, we're going to cross the team
when we wake up tomorrow.
He looks at me, he goes, bet.
We do it.
The next morning we wake up.
Sure enough, it's fine.
No way.
Fast forward, fast forward to five years later.
This is this quarter, this last quarter.
I call him again and I go, John, you want to make some money, buddy?
He's like, what do you got this time, man?
And I go like, you have an account on this particular site that I want to use.
I'm banned.
Can you just go and do this?
He goes, well, I have a problem with my account.
I'm like, perfect.
That's even better.
Can you try this?
Sure enough, tries it.
Another blind cross-screening starts off.
It's just getting an understanding of how these companies work, what requires them to manually
have someone click on your page and then you assuming this is the information they're going
to see about.
I'm wondering, is there any merit to sending your cross, say it's some sort of logging
endpoint or something like that.
Is there any merit to sending it on a time-based basis?
Okay.
Like every five minutes, we're going to send another one through.
Because whenever somebody first opens up the admin portal, there's always going to be a page
a paginated list or something like that.
And if you land in that first 25 or whatever, then you might get in that front area.
Have you ever thought about that or tried anything like that?
I haven't done it on purpose because when you do stuff in a time manner, it's a little bit
spammy and it's the last thing I want.
Is, but I've had that happen a couple of times.
A couple of fun ones is it asks you for a note sometimes.
I put on the note, it doesn't fire.
It doesn't fire on their backend.
They copy my note into the internal app and then it fires.
Right?
I've seen that happen before.
Do you do?
The typical like in my email was a fun one.
One of the really cool one was a website.
My password was a blank cross-screen payload.
No, it was not.
Oh my gosh.
That fired once.
This is just me copy pasting the same thing for my name, email, everything.
And then the password was clear text.
Plain text.
It was sending a clear text.
No way.
That's ridiculous, man.
That one hasn't happened.
This was like eight, nine years ago.
This was like, no, not, yes.
Uh, 2015, 2016.
So six, seven years ago.
Wow.
It happened.
It's just, it's just, you know, you never know, right?
You never know.
There's a couple of times where it's fired off in a engineer's like local machine
because they downloaded everybody's feedback.
And they were parsing it.
That's crazy.
That's so cool.
And, and so with that, I kind of want to ask, how do you track where your payload source
was?
Because what, what always happens to me when I do blind XSS is all, is all tight, you know,
throw this payload in there and then I'll get a callback.
And then I'm like, where did I put that in a form somewhere?
You know?
And then how do I record it?
Let me ask you a question.
What are you doing for tracking?
What are you using a cross-screen?
Are you using like an XSS Hunter?
Yeah.
I'm just using XSS Hunter, normal XSS Hunter from Truffle.
Question number two.
If you give, oh, okay.
That's why.
Oh, I don't know how that works.
I don't know if Truffle allows you to do this.
Can you give it a path?
What do you, oh yeah.
Like a specific path at the end?
Oh, that's what you're getting your own path.
You only get one path.
Yeah.
Oh, so see, this is what I do.
I have my own domain.
Yeah.
If you go to the London event, it was spammed everywhere.
I think they were like trolling me at some point.
So I started deleting it, but I have a domain that is not a, it's a, it's a cross-site, it's a
XSS Hunter JavaScript without the backend of XSS Hunter.
So it's just a JavaScript that they have.
Yeah.
And it, it just hooks into a PHP file and that PHP file is what processes the entire, like when it
fires, right?
That's the backend is a PHP file.
That's like garbage.
It's actually written by chat GPT, I shit you not.
Oh my gosh.
The, the, the front end of it, I have a HTT access rule in there that catches every single
path you give and it serves that JavaScript file if it, if it's not valid.
So my 404 is that JS file that pops up.
So when I do a cross-site, you know, when I do a blind XSS, I do domain.com slash whatever I
want to make a note of.
So the note could be first name in profile.
That's an invalid path.
So when it fires, it fires with my JS file and it shows me where it's at.
But a lot of times it's also easy to track because you know, it's something like your name
or you know, your password and things like that.
It's obvious.
The feedback ones are always the hardest one to track, but a lot of companies don't
care where it came from because they know where it came from.
Yeah.
They know where it came from.
That's, that's really crazy.
Yeah.
I mean, I can't imagine in scenarios where developers are like copy and pasting your
data into different applications or something like that, how you trace it back to the source.
It has to be done on the company side, I imagine.
That one was a hard one because yeah, there was some issues with that one.
I'd be like, oh, well you message RT.
I'm like, no, I didn't message anybody.
They copy, pasted this dude.
And I'm like, I did not say this to them.
And it turned out it was a note that I left.
They copied the note into the internal app and then it fired.
Wow.
That's crazy, man.
What a crazy hacking story.
Yeah.
I know your XSS Hunter instance, because I know Mr. Sam McCreary likes to use it.
And I have my own XSS Hunter setup.
That's not mine.
The only person that uses mine is...
That one's not?
No, I think that's X.
That's not mine.
That's XSS.
I also use that domain sometimes.
You must be using your script because I was looking through it and there's a bunch of
the HomSec references in the JS.
It could be that they're using a version of it.
I shared that with everybody in you guys' group.
I have no problem with using it because it's not something I wrote.
I also saw Sean using it in a specific way I incorporated in mine.
But the biggest thing that I have is the PHP file on the backend.
And me and Zyed have a...
I can't actually say the name of our bot.
I'll send you guys the name of the bot later.
But we have a bot that we've created.
I almost said the name.
It could have gotten me in a lot of trouble.
But we have...
The name of the bot is the name of the CEO of the company.
Okay.
So we have a...
We have a...
And then the team has also seen this bot when I screenshot it for them.
That's so funny.
We have a bot that it just says like,
Hey everyone on Discord, it's at everyone new blog and content scripting.
And it gets the URL from that report.
And then also links to the report that I have as a text file.
I store it all on my server.
It's password protected.
You know, we have to have a credential to log into it.
And I just go look at it and then analyze it and things like that.
That system is one of the most
fucked up, addicting things I've ever done.
Because when I was getting a lot of blogging scripting, dude,
I was waking up at 5am rolling over and looking at my phone
to see if a new one popped up.
And then when you see it popped and you can't go back to sleep.
Yeah.
It's the same thing.
So...
Yeah, dude, I just set up my own XSS Hunter.
And I saw how yours was set up because I thought it was like standard.
And I really like it because I'm going to set up something to do the same thing with like the
path catch all and the subdomain catch all.
Yeah, that's brilliant.
Because...
Man, Ben, rocking it as always.
Okay, this next episode is from episode 59,
entitled Bug Bounty Gadget Hunting and Hackers Intuition.
And personally, this was my favorite episode of the year.
Just sitting down with Joel, talking through all of these bug bounty gadgets that we have,
and how to sort of duct tape them all together was a blast.
So if I had to pick one episode, you know, maybe tooting my own horn a little bit here,
since this is a Justin and Joel episode.
But this episode, I think, has a lot of really good takeaways in it.
And we did cut a segment for you.
It specifically is talking about HTML injection, image injection in particular,
and then moving into Open Redirect, client-side path traversal, and client-side Open Redirect,
which is a little bit of a weird bug. So I think you guys will enjoy it.
Check out this segment.
I think about one of my favorite volumes, and I think I've talked about this on the pod before,
but I'll mention it again.
And this was an image injection, okay?
And this is not even like...
I wasn't breaking out of any context.
And we'll kind of talk about context breaks a little bit later as a gadget in and of themselves.
But if you're able to inject into the source attribute of an image,
there's some weird stuff you can do.
Okay.
And especially if you can do it in a targeted way.
For example, there was a scenario, much like the Dingley markup example that I gave just a second ago,
where I was able to do a stored image injection on somebody, essentially, within an application,
okay?
And I could force the browser to load up a specific image.
And then what I did is I forced them to hit the logout endpoint.
Mm-hmm.
With the image tag.
Through the image tag?
Yeah.
So essentially, I would send them a message, and then that message would get pushed to their,
you know, dashboard or whatever.
And that dashboard would have an image.
And then as soon as they log into their dashboard, it would load that image and log them out.
And then as soon as they tried to do anything on the application, it would get,
it would, they'd get logged out and they'd be forced to reauth.
And then when they reauth, they would go back to the dashboard page.
Wow.
And, you know, and so there's a couple of ways that you can exploit this.
I actually exploited it again recently in a scenario where there wasn't a logout CSERF,
but there was a log in CSERF.
Oh.
So, so you can, you could essentially repeatedly log them into a different account,
and then they could never get access to their own account.
Wow.
Okay.
So it, it's, it's, it's sort of a tricky exploit for sure.
Um, but image injection, and then I know there used to be like, like 401 injection or something
like that.
I don't know if that works in any browsers.
Yeah.
We kind of, we, we keep on talking about that and then we still don't know.
Um, but I know so at one point people were using 401 injection on an image in image source.
Uh, and that would pop up a, an off box that would allow you to exfiltrate off, um, under a different
sites domain.
In fact, our friend, Mr.
Sam Curry has an, has a disclosed report on Twitter from 2017.
Oh my gosh.
Sam, what have you done?
Marked as a low, marked as a low.
That, uh, is exactly this.
HTM, HTB 401 response injection.
Hey guys, real quick.
I want to remind you about the critical thinking discord community.
There's been a ton of great activity on the chats lately.
People just kind of shooting the breeze to drop in new hacking tips and advice, uh, sharing cool
research, that sort of thing.
Uh, so it's definitely something you're going to want to get in on if you haven't already.
Also, we've got the subscriber tiers in place now, which will give you access to really cool things
like masterclass, AMA, uh, just random scripts that I drop.
It's kind of like our inner circle.
Um, so if you want to get in on that, please do.
We would really appreciate it.
Also, it helps support the show.
So if you're interested in any of that, head over to ctvb.show slash discord to join the community
today and we'll see you over there.
All right, back to the show.
I don't know.
There are some edge cases in which this might work in mobile browsers or in like Firefox
or something like that.
So if you're really, really grasping for straws, you know, in a live hacking event and you're like,
I got to find something here, you know, then it might be, might be worth a report.
It might land you a low, but, um, definitely the stuff with the targeted image injection.
I mean, to be honest, that can get you into a high.
Yeah.
Because if you can literally just DOS the whole app for a targeted user, that's availability high.
I mean, I feel like that's, that's impact right there.
If you can figure out some way to, to, to demonstrate that, then, then there you go.
Right.
So speaking of, uh, desperate, desperateness and, uh, you know, if you're really desperate,
report this, uh, open redirects, let's talk about open redirects because, um, as from the program
side, I see this a lot, actually, um, where people report open redirects with no impact.
And, um, what do you think about that?
I, I could not recommend,
against it any, any stronger.
Like, like, don't do that.
Wow.
That's, that's a strong position.
Like, I really, I think open redirects are like one of the lamest bug classes by itself.
And like, there really is like no impact in today's day and age, right?
Like, uh, like just by itself, like I can send you to a link, you go to another link at best fishing.
Like, yeah, it's, it's a very, very hard use case, um, an exploitation case I find, but what you can do
with that, there are a ton of things, right?
Um, a couple of great examples, SRFs.
A lot of times there'll be either a filter on the URL that's being, that you're being sent to, or that's
being requested to, that needs to be within a certain host name or within a certain IP range.
Um, you can use that as a redirect to go to, you know, AWS metadata or something.
Yeah.
Um, we, we, we've seen that, you know, that, that technique has been around forever and stuff like
that. So that, that that's definitely a tried and true use case for open redirects. The ones that I'm,
I'm more interested in nowadays are the OAuth path traversals, essentially you being able to
leak an OAuth token via, uh, uh, open redirect. And the, the ones that I, I think are actually more
interesting are, uh, client-side path traversals and, or iframe injections, essentially, uh, iframe
source injections. So, you know, if you can, if you can provide a, a place where you're supposed
to be able to embed any page on, uh, on a specific website in an application, then you can use an,
ifr, an open redirect in that, in that, uh, environment to get your own page embedded in there.
Um, that's, that's a scenario that once again is a gadget that can, that can, uh, expose a lot of, um,
um, helpful things like post message listeners. Um, you know, in, in, in mobile's case, you know,
sometimes you can get it, use it for like, um, like JavaScript, what are they called?
JavaScript bridges or something like that, Joel?
Joel Pfeiffer 1 Yep.
Joel Pfeiffer 1 Yeah.
Joel Pfeiffer 1 Yeah. So just, you know, accessing specific functions or, or, um, parameters on the
window object to interact with the actual application. Um, really cool purposes there. And dude, this is
the one that just like lately has been just so, so cool to see work. We talk about client-side path
traversals all the time and client-side path traversals are kind of a gadget of themselves. Um, but this is a
great example where you can put two gadgets together to make a vault, right? So let's say you've got a
client-side path traversal. So essentially what, what that means is you're able to control, um,
either the, the, the place to which a fetch request is sent, or like maybe even an iframe that's
embedded dynamically using JavaScript or something like that. Um, uh, but normally the fetch scenario
is, is where it's at and you're able to inject into that URL scheme and traverse and then hit an open
redirect. So I saw somebody at the live hacking event do this.
Joel Pfeiffer 1 I was gonna say.
Joel Pfeiffer 1 Yeah. And, and I also, my mentee sitting right there at that, at that desk behind me
found one the other day and fully exploited it. And I was just like, dude, this bug is like so clutch.
Joel Pfeiffer 1 Yeah.
Joel Pfeiffer 1 And so I really love to see it used with the client-side
path traversal where you traverse, hit the open redirect fetch automatically follows redirects. Um,
which I don't know, I won't go down the path of, of whining about that, uh, bug that I found
recently where I couldn't actually exploit it because fetch auto follows redirects and you can't
even read the redirect location ever. Um, but, uh, but seeing that actually work out in a client-side
path traversal environment is amazing. And it's so often works out to be XSS, even in like heavily
sanitized environments, because they're not expecting malicious input to come back from a fetch request
that they sent to their own API. Right. Right. So there's pretty much no way to, to, you know,
properly anticipate that. Um, so that's a really cool use case for an open redirect.
Joel Pfeiffer 1 Yeah. I mean, there's so much protection and advice on the server side with SRF,
right? Where it's like, okay, never take a user control parameter and make a request to it and all
this stuff. But then like so much of that falls to the wayside on the client side, because it's just not
the same thought process and there's so much different development around like, you know,
it seems very harmless, right? You're like, Oh, I'm just getting a query parameter or something.
And, but that that's all it takes, you know, that that's just putting it in a fetch request. And
because of that behavior and the ubiquity of, um, you know, open redirects and all that kind of stuff,
it just makes it such a larger problem. And with all these single page applications nowadays,
it's, you know, even more so. Right. Um, so, so yeah, really, really interesting stuff there.
Yeah. So I don't know about what you said about the open redirect. I think open redirect is right
on the line of like, if a company is really taking security seriously, they want to clean that up
because it can be used in so many scenarios. Right. Um, but don't be surprised if it's a low,
Oh yeah. You know what? Like by face value, you know what I mean?
It's never more than a low.
If you report it, like, they're just going to be like, okay, I guess we'll fix this, but like
Do something for sure. Yeah. Um, and, and that scenario do really rarely you report that because
it's, it's, uh, much more high value to be able to use it in the chain, even if it's not present
rather than, excuse me, man, water this morning, um, rather than chaining it into something that's,
you know, much higher value, uh, down the line. Yeah. So, and I will say, I think it probably every
single live hacking event at least once I see in the collab channel, somebody go, Hey, does anybody
have an open redirect? I need an open redirect. Yeah. And you're like, ah, okay. Yeah. This is
still a thing. This is still kicking. So, um, definitely check that out.
You know, what's interesting about that too, is for all the people there that don't need an open
redirect, but might have an open redirect, like that should be inspiration for you. Right. Because
somebody needs an open redirect, which means that the open redirect that you have somewhere,
there is a use case for that, you know, and you just gotta go find it. And the fact that that
happens every single live hacking event really sort of lends itself to the scenario of like,
Oh, I have an open redirect, but I can't really find anything to do with it. Well,
that's definitely out there. You know, somebody's there's definitely some place. There's some use
cases. Exactly. Exactly. So that, that should be inspiration for any of you that either need an
open redirect or, or, uh, don't need an open redirect and should need an open redirect. Um,
yeah, absolutely. Uh, so sort of tangential gadget to that is the client side open redirect. And this
one I actually think is garbage. And I actually was, there's a pretty serious differentiation between
client side redirect, open redirect and a server side open redirect. Right. Um,
depending on the scenario, you know, you still may be able to use it. The pretty much the only use
I could come up with is iframe, uh, iframe source injection, essentially. Like there's pretty much
nothing else you can really do with it. If you're doing like a window location.href and you cannot
do the JavaScript scheme, then you're, I mean, you're, you're pretty much screwed. It doesn't,
it doesn't leak the hash. It doesn't leak any of the query parameters. It just goes to the location
that you define with the input that you inputted. Um, and so I don't know, maybe I'm missing something
there and I'd be interested if anyone in the community can point me in the direction of something
that I might be able to do with this besides, you know, injecting into an iframe, but that's pretty
much the only thing I could come up with. Yeah. I'm trying to think if there's anything creative,
probably the best scenario I can come up with is like maybe on mobile, depending on the permissions
within a web view, you could redirect to a file or something like that. Um, and then, you know,
pivot from there depending on, but, but that's going to be very situation specific. Um, so yeah,
I mean, it's one of those things that as a, again, as a gadget, like it potentially has use cases, but
they're very, very narrow, especially even for the ones that we've been talking about, like client side
open redirect is, is really like, you know, one in a hundred type barely, barely ever use, uh, but,
but it's there and have it in the back of your mind. You know, what is not, not a vulnerability,
but, and it's not really even a gadget, but kind of feels like one is a post message open redirect.
Yeah. And I've, I've kind of run into this scenario a lot where it's like, okay, I'm really close to
XSS because if I could just send this post message to redirect the page to a JavaScript URI, then I'd
have XSS, but you can't use the JavaScript URI because of some, you know, very tough to bypass
anesthetization or something, but you can redirect the URL to an arbitrary host. Yeah. But it's,
it's useless because essentially you, unless it's in an iframe, I guess is the only scenario that that
would actually be useful. And then you could say like, you know, window.open X is, is the new
window, right? Right. And then dot frames one, and then send the post message to that or whatever,
and have it redirect inside the trusted page. Then it's a little bit useful, but, um, you can always
just redirect the other tab that you've opened up anyway with window.open. So you just do, you know,
X equals window.open and then X dot location equals X, Y, Z, and then you've redirected a page to that
location. Or you just name the windows. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. And so, um, that didn't make the list
this time around, uh, on the, on the gadget side, but as an honorable mention, uh, and also something
that I would kind of be interested to see if anyone like knows any way that that could be helpful.
Maybe the only thing that I could think of is like, ah, it could maybe be helpful in like a same site
strict scenario, right? Where like, you can't even do top level navigations to send the cookies.
You've got to actually come from a specific origin. And if you could trigger the redirect from
the origin, then you could trigger get based sea surf on a same site strict scenario.
Yeah. I mean, and again, right. It's like one of those really like stretch scenarios. It's going to
be super, super specific to, you know? Yeah. I don't know. I'm trying to think if there's anything
and I keep falling back to like these more like native scenarios where like an electron app or like
something that has more schemes or like stuff that, you know, stuff other than JavaScript and other than
HTML or sorry, HTTP, or HTTPS, um, that maybe you could, you could exploit in some creative way, but, uh,
yeah, I don't know. It's, it's very, very tricky.
See, see what I'm saying? That was pretty good, right? That was a good segment. I, I want to, I
want to put out more content like that where we're really breaking down, um, you know, technical
gadgets, components and showing innovative ways to duct tape them all together. All right, cool.
So this next segment is actually going to be from Sam Curry. This is episode 65 motivation and
methodology with Sam Curry. Um, you know, I don't even have to tell you about Sam Curry. Sam Curry's a
freaking legend. Um, he, he has some of the most amazing hacks I've ever seen, very unique hacker.
Um, and in this segment, he comes on the pod and talks about the vulnerability class that he coined
secondary context, patroversals, um, which I was just working on one a couple of days ago, very common
vulnerability, um, exploiting it takes a lot of expertise and Sam kind of gives us some thoughts
on how to do that. Um, utilizing both hacker intuition and sort of hands-on methodology. So let's jump to that
clip. So Sam, you have so much research online, so many stories, um, so many cool things that, uh,
we need to unpack here, but one of the things you are most well known for is secondary context bugs.
Um, I don't know, did you like my first exposure to secondary context was you, uh, did you, did you
coin that term? Same. I did. Yes. It was funny. It's, I appreciate it. Yeah. It's funny seeing
that term like news. Cause I'm like, Oh my God, someone's actually using that word. I just put
those two things together. That's like a talk title. That's clutch, man. But it, it, it, I mean,
obviously I'm sure some OG, you know, on some blog back in like, you know, 28, well, you know,
20, 28, 28, 28, 2008. Yeah. No, um, you know, way back wrote something about it, but, uh, you know,
that blog or that talk that you did on secondary context stuff was my first exposure to that. Um,
and, and I think it, it, it really made it more, uh, widely recognized in the industry. Um, and we
have a cool, cool bug. We can talk about that with the Starbucks bug. Um, and that's on samcurry.net as
well, uh, that you guys can go read about, but talk to me about when you started realizing
secondary context bugs were a thing and how you started working through that whole concept.
Right. Yeah. So my initial exposure to like secondary context bugs was on, uh,
Yahoo's luminate, which was like Yahoo's small business platform for like deploying websites and
stuff. And what I realized was that, uh, I originally thought it was like paths, like file path traversal,
right? Because I was like able to traverse and like add directories.
And I'd been spending so long on this one app and I was just like getting, and I eventually
started testing for it. And I'm like, Oh my God, there's file path traversal. And even in,
it's funny too, because I blogged about it. And even in the blog post, I refer to it as like,
I remember this, you know, local file. I remember this. So this was not a file path traversal.
It was not. Yeah. It was actually HB path traversal. But even at the time, like,
I'm like, I guess that's password file just didn't exist. And it's like, no, that's just not,
that's not what was happening. Um, so with that kind of exposure to it, uh, I started looking for
similar stuff in more and more places. And I eventually realized that like the internet was
slowly being built towards this like interesting, like network model where like, oh, you want to
serve a CDN from like www.yahoo.com where like you want to serve images, but you don't have to like,
you've got this very complicated configuration of like proxy rules and different passes. So maybe that,
you know, slash images, instead of being like a folder on like one box because of like load
balance, how crazy that would be if it was just all served from the same box. Now the slash images
route is being proxied to like some internal server for a CDN, right? That's interesting. Do you think
this is a function of needing to do load balancing more effectively? I think it's a mix of things,
right? I think that, um, if you're a team who you have like, you know, maybe a static blog,
but at the same time, like you have, uh, authentication functionality on your static blog
and the team who deploys, you know, you've got like DevOps team one, DevOps team two, and then like,
you have to kind of merge them together. Sometimes the easiest way to like differentiate routes and
folders and things I think is by adding that reverse proxy and then separating the services into two.
Um, yeah. So that's probably the biggest thing that I've seen from like the engineering side is
it's the service, like that service aspect. A lot of people don't think about this because they're not
in engineering org, but for engineering orgs, like they split up functionality into services,
right? And services are separately deployed. And in order for these things to interact with each
other, instead of having just one giant application, that's handling everything from one place that can
interact internally with everything itself. It has to make some sort of call, whether that's like
gRPC or Kafka or whatever, like, and a lot of times it's just HTTP. They build an HTTP client,
like for that service that just like calls internal endpoints on that other service on, you know,
their internal network and it passes data back and forth. And it's a lot, you know, it's a lot more
simple than people would think where they're like, oh, like, you know, they must have, they're,
they're load balancing. It's like, no, they, there's two separate services and they have to talk to each
other somehow. And they just did that with an HTTP request and they did it really, really quickly and
effectively in a, in an insecure way. And that's where things are starting to fall apart.
Right. Yeah, exactly. And like, even, uh, external services too, like API, it's like, maybe you've got
like a maps plugin, like you want to serve that data and you pass in a path that goes to like Google
maps API. And like, it's very, very interesting how like complicated it goes. I think one of the
reasons like this kind of research kind of came about, there's different people who had worked on
like similar things in the past. There's really excellent blog posts, like Franz Rosen. Um, he,
he should have been like, he should be the originator. Um, his work with like Matthias and others,
like I think probably even a few years before that talk. And I even messaged him when I gave a talk,
I said like, I feel like this is similar to a lot of work that you've done in the past. And I was
like, if there's anything here, like, I'm going to make sure to credit you for a lot of this. Um,
I want to make sure I'm not like stepping on your toes a little bit, but, uh, I wanted to say like the,
the way that, the way that I totally lost my train of thought, but maybe I can, maybe I can redirect
you. That's fine. The, the, so as you're starting to develop this, this understanding of
essentially modern web architecture where these reverse proxies are in, are in place like that.
Um, and the, the tricky part for me still lies in where does the authentication live? Because there's,
there's a lot of, there's a lot of, uh, secondary context pass diversals all over the place, but
the backend server is also using auth and it's just like, okay, well I can hit a different endpoint,
you know, and sometimes you can do weird stuff with that. Like, like sea surfs or like, um, you know,
some sort of, um, method confusion and that sort of thing. But, uh, the majority of the time that
understanding that off piece is really, is really pivotal, right?
Right. Yeah. A hundred percent. I mean, the off component is so important to everything because
like, if you're a, like a lot of structures, for instance, uh, we saw this a lot in the car hacking
where, uh, as an example, like you have Sirius XM at the top where there's all these different
vehicle brands beneath it, like Ford, you know, whatever. But the Sirius XM service is like the
authenticated ones. So each of those car companies has like an API key that they use globally. So
it's like, once you, if you can leak that key, change the context between like one user with access
to one thing, and then like you leak the key and then you can talk to that service directly access
to that backend service. Yeah, exactly. Right. So one example there is like, you know,
maybe you're fuzzing for, you know, secondary context stuff and you throw in like a new line
character for a URI parameter instead of like your account ID, maybe you do one, two, three percent zero D
and then you get a stack trace back where it's like the API call to internal.company.com
question mark API key equals. And you're like, aha, I see the API key. You take that. And then you're
like, Hey team, this is allowing me to access anybody's stuff. So you give it to them, right?
But like you said, the authentic, the off, yeah, it's, it's tricky to figure out.
Maybe, yeah, maybe, maybe it is, but, uh, you know, doing some, uh,
hacking on the program recently and I don't know if you can disclose their bugs, but there's a lot of
similar stuff like there, right. With the, with the secondary context stuff.
Yeah. It's like, uh, yeah, there's tons of, uh, a lot of the, for instance, like a lot of people hunt
for actuators like really heavily. And like when you start exploring like actuator secondary context
stuff, it's really fun because it's like, you know, in some JavaScript file somewhere, there's like this
route, which is a reverse proxy. Maybe it's like API GW dash, you know, internal slash or something.
Then you hit that route and then that's where you append your actuator ends or like dot dot
semicolon slash actuator ends. And then like, it lets you kind of hunt more thoroughly.
I guess in this scenario, you're hitting dev API, API dev endpoints using this, this, um,
new secondary context sort of path traversal. So going through the front end,
then traversing on the backend, hitting these actuator endpoints, which wouldn't be
exposed publicly because of probably path limitations, um, through the reverse proxy.
And, and then like, are you normally hunting for things where it's going to dump the full response
back to you without any modification? Or are you, you know, trying to hit these things blind?
Because a lot of times there's a parsing of the response from that backend API. And then that,
that kind of hex up your, your visibility into the backend. Right.
Right. Yeah. The, having a response is beautiful. It makes you so happy when you see that HP response
leaked back to you, you feel amazing, but a lot of times it is blind. Right. And I was with another
researcher Nathaniel. It really is. Um, it's like a, I would say too, like to finish up a bit, like, uh,
Nathaniel Latimer, Donut. Um, I was with him on a trip and I like storm into his hotel room,
like manically with my laptop. I'm like, if I do that, that slash ABC, it doesn't do anything.
But if you do that slash XYZ, it does this thing, but like, I can't reproduce it on this one.
And like, he he's looking at me, I've sat there for six hours trying to figure it out. And he's like,
this guy, like, what is he talking about? Like, it's absurd because there are so many conditionals
that relate to like the, uh, you know, like you're trying to explain to your friend, you're like,
if I do a pound sign, it does this behavior. And if I do an ampersand, it's this behavior.
And like, you have to like really build out this like brain map for each individual case. Right.
I think the most complicated, like secondary context bug I had was like this stored, uh,
you would add a value to a database with like an amp sign and like change the print,
you change the format from XML to JSON. Yeah. And then like on another endpoint,
you'd call it and you'd get retrieved it. Like, and it was just like,
How did you identify? So it's like a stored secondary context. I've never even thought about a stored
secondary context. Yeah. Uh, logically a lot of times, uh, it can be,
some things I think you can look for there if it's like external services, like external APIs that,
you know, for instance, uh, you know, are, are they leveraging some third party API that has an API key
or like, or is there one you've already identified that's like, you can kind of add onto. Um, but
they're so case by case, right? Like one service has like one behavior and you have, you have to build
those mind maps, I guess. Yeah. And when you're talking about the external services,
it makes me, it reminds me of the Starbucks bug and just to give a quick overview of this,
um, like essentially what in this scenario, we actually had access to the full response,
right? That was coming back. And, and we were able to, on that one, we were able to path traverse
back on, on the Starbucks API and hit, it was, it was a third party, right? It was Microsoft. Was it graph?
Yeah. It was a Microsoft graph search. I think it was like, uh, they had like a,
I don't know if there was a third party service or it was a utility they had, but it was connected to
their core, their, their core Starbucks, a hundred million user records was it was connected to.
Yeah. And so essentially like we were working on this together and what amazed me when we were
working on this together was one that you identified one that leaked the full response,
which allowed us to get so much more, I just did data back. But, um, uh, but for two,
you were able to brute force these paths along the way. And I just, I don't know, man, I don't know.
Maybe it's just because I don't do a lot of brute forcing as a part of my methodology,
but it's just, that's just some, and Franz Franz does it even weirder. I mean, Franz
brute forces it as well, but Franz also just has like this sixth sense of like, you know what I bet
customer is before this. And it's like, and then he'll guess because we were working on this target
and it was like, it was, we weren't allowed to brute force. They said explicitly, literally no
brute force. Please do not brute force it. Okay. And so we're like, we need to brute force it.
Cause how are we going to figure out the paths, you know, that we're traversing. And Franz just
guessed four paths deep. And I'm like, you've got to be kidding me, man. Um, so I guess for this,
in your experience with the brute forcing, what is your approach to that? What word lists are you
using? Are you generating custom things? You know, is it just something I've got to start doing it that
I'm not doing? Yeah. I mean, a really, a really simple list I like to use, um, it's in burp by default,
but it's like server side variable names and it's just like, you know, path parameter.
Yeah. Exili, Mike Robert showed me this, like he uses it from time to time for like parameters
and stuff. But I think if you go to the simple list, it's like server side variable names. But, uh,
the thought process for trying to brute force the paths or guess the paths is like,
one, it lets you confirm that like, you're not just traversing to like the same request you're on.
Cause a lot of the times what will happen is like, you think you're traversing, but in reality,
it's like a normal side, like API request where it's been condensed down to the normal request.
So you're actually just calling yourself. So, um, but yeah, it's very, you're like, oh,
I'm just, you know, you like spam so I'm out and you're like, delete our messages. Like, nevermind,
ignore me. Um, but the, uh, but brute forcing the paths is really fun because like,
you know, you can kind of guess like, for instance, if it's Franz, I've misprounced his name for 10 years,
you know, so I apologize. Um, but he, he would doing customer like makes a lot of sense where
you can kind of guess the format ish, like D1, you know, V2, V3, whatever, but building it out.
Um, I wish there was more general tips, but it really is case by case basis. You know,
are they using camel case, lowercase, upper, are they separating the front end,
like paths for that to, to determine that information or you, because I guess at some point
it's getting proxied back through. So maybe they're using similar name conventions on the back end as
well. Yeah. That's, that's one thing that, uh, you can kind of pick up on is like on the front end,
if they refer to your account as like account underscore ID or something like that, you know,
those variable names that are like normal, you can kind of like interplace those. Um,
most of the time I'll just send it through. If there's no rate limiting, I have like a massive
word list that Chubbs gave me that is like 500,000 or something. Yeah, that's a note word list.
They're really good. Yeah. All right. All right. Next up is Johan Carlson,
three month check-in on full-time bug bounty. That's episode 69. Um, and we took a snippet in
this one talking specifically about highly CSP environments and how Johan was, I don't know,
what's that quote from like Bane? Like I was born in the darkness, you know, Johan was born in the
highly CSP environment. Um, and so he has some really great takeaways about how to survive in that,
in that environment, um, specifically by the use of script gadgets and how, um, various pieces of
code can be monitoring the Dom for, uh, various, um, patterns, you know, query selectors, that sort of
thing of things being added to the Dom, which may even make it past, um, uh, Dom purify or something
of the like, uh, and then how to utilize and chain those gadgets together, uh, to create an exploit in
those highly CSP environments. So definitely a good one. Check this one out. And the, the other thing
that I wanted to kind of bring up and highlight here is this whole concept. So we talk about gadgets
on the pod a lot, right? Um, one of the things that we haven't talked about quite as much is this whole
concept of a script, script gadget within the page in these high CSP environments. How can we convert,
um, you know, HTML injection into something a little bit more functional using these pieces
of, of script, uh, that already exist, uh, on the page. So, um, it's reading through a couple of
your other pieces of, of work and this as well, it's become clear to me that, um, this is one of
your, your, this is your jam. And this is, in my mind, you're, you're one of the most foremost experts
on the specific sort of gadget, uh, of sorts. Um, so I want you to give us a little bit of insight into,
um, how exactly this, how you discover these, um, sort of events. And I, obviously you can look at
like hash changes and stuff like that. So anytime we're trying to explain anything in these sort of
environments, it's always great to like go to global listeners, open your dev tool, go to global
listeners, look at the hash change event and kind of see what, what code is going to be running on
hash change. But looking at the, the write-up you passed along to me as well, there's like, you know,
there are events happening when there's a specific, uh, class, uh, of object being added to the dom
and like sorts of things like that, that are just way out there. So how are you finding these in the
first place in order to construct this like beautiful chain? It's a, I think probably it's quite funny
because when I started, like I was looking into, so when I did my thesis way back, the, the GitLab thing,
yeah. Uh, we were one of the things that we did then was that we downloaded like all the
disclosed reports from GitLab, uh, into a spreadsheet, me and my thesis partner. Uh, so when we started,
we, we read like, and at that time I didn't know anything about this, like, uh, security or like,
uh, but we read like all of these reports, like one after another, uh, and some things stood out and
you sort of realized that at that time, at least like William Wax, he was like the, the main antagonist
on GitLab. Like he was crushing it with the RCEs and stuff at that time on like XSS and, uh, so I just,
uh, studied his, uh, works and classic move. Highly, highly recommend that to anyone who has the time.
Yeah. So what mimicry is the serious form of flattery, right? That's true. Yeah. And we're from where I was
coming from. I was like, okay, so this is how you do it. Like you have to find these gadgets and you
have to do all of this. And like, because I was starting, I found my first, uh, cross site scripting,
like by super accident just after, um, I had been doing this research, like the, the thesis paper for
three months, uh, like trying putting payloads everywhere and stuff like that. Didn't find anything.
And then the summer came and I was done with school and everything and I had passed and everything was
fine. And I just got this, uh, like feeling I was at my parents, uh, like having some summer vacation.
And I just thought like, okay, I'm going to just go in and try this. I had this one injection point that I,
I wanted to do something. You could name like a default repository, uh, thing. And so when someone
creates a project and it's, it shows you some instructions, like run these commands to create
an empty repository or whatever. Uh, and I know that I, you could put something in there and I just
went there and just added a super basic, like script alert thing. And then it popped. And I was like,
what? I mean, I was like, no, no, it can't be that easy. And also like, I know that I tested this,
like just a couple of weeks back and after all of this happened. And later I looked and the code change
was just like two weeks old. Uh, so it was like super just like by this accident that I went there,
like, and they actually changed the code between me first testing it and then testing it again.
Wow. That's wild. It's crazy.
But, and then I, I stumbled. So that popped on my local thing. And then I went to gitlab.com and I was
like, yeah, I'm going to get this like super awesome high paying bug now and nothing happened.
And that was my first encounter with the CSP. Like I have not, I had never heard about it before.
I just opened the console and it said like CSP blocked. I was like, what?
Dun, dun, dun, dun. From that day on, Johan was triggered anytime he saw a CSP.
Yeah. So, and then I went and just, uh, so, and so some people had already used some of these gadgets
before on GitLab. Uh, and then, uh, I found some of my own as well, uh, just by essentially like
reading the source code and like grepping for these kinds of behaviors where it's like looking for.
I, I kind of went from the sink. Like I found places where it did like fetch requests. I have a
few reports where I can do like this client side, uh, attacks where I could create some element and it will
be replaced by some form that I can control the path. And then I can just make like one
put request to the API. But with that one request, you can make yourself an admin. If it's like an admin
who clicks the link or whatever. So it seems to me just from hearing that explanation and looking at
your, you know, hacker one history and, and that sort of thing that you're, you're just, this is a
function of you being sort of growing as a hacker in a highly CSP environment. Because I think most
people don't start off at GitLab and don't start off at, you know, some of these other more hardened
targets that have these CSPs in place. So we're all used to, oh wait, you know, the, the HTML is
reflecting boom XSS, you know, game over. But, but, um, because you kind of grew, grew as a hacker in
this highly CSP environment, there's always that extra step for you and it forced you to adapt.
And these adaptations look like these script gadgets and these, you know, sort of far out ways to get
around CSP. And, and you kind of, you can see that they are also like shared between in GitLab, you can
see even the non-disclosed reports. You can often see them in their like issue tracker later. Uh, and
you can see like these, so I, in the beginning, I used some of the VACs, uh, like CSP bypasses, and then
I found some of my own and then I have also seen like other people use mine and you get like proud.
Like, yeah, way to go. And now they, they actually like just a couple of weeks ago, they, they killed
one of the absolutely the best ones that was like, uh, because what you want, uh, you want something
that also can pass Dom purify, right. And still work as a script gadget after Dom purify. And they
had like this one that, uh, I know like a lot of people have used it. Like it's, I think that VACs
found it like three years ago and they have never, like, come on, let's go.
Uh, it was just like, uh, like a, quite same kind of functionality. Like you, you put, um,
and, uh, they think at least like in the code, they thought that they were targeting a form.
So they were looking for forms, uh, and that a form that had like one class and classes are like,
yeah, you can put that through Dom purify itself. Wow. I thought it was going to be a data
attribute. I'm not going to lie, but it was a class. Okay. Interesting.
Yeah. It was a class. So this was like a custom code that looked for this class on the form they
called it, but you could actually put this class on anything, but then it looked for an, uh, an input
element in this form. So the, the input element actually needed to be an input element, but the
form could be anything. And you can get those through Dom purify. Input elements are fine and forms
as well, uh, by default, but the Git lab is actually stripping forms. But so that was the
good part about this gadget because you, it didn't have to be a form. It could be a div or whatever.
Awesome. Uh, and then it would look at this input element and for some reason it would take
like the title, which is also fine through Dom purify and do some sort of like replacement,
putting it in the Dom, like whatever you put there. So then you could have like a, some,
something that popped and it would also then be valid because it was coming through with like the,
the nonce through the CSP, right. And like inheritance. Doesn't that need to be like, um,
it's not in some cases it's unsafe eval, but like strict dynamic or something like that.
Strict dynamic. Yeah. Okay. So that's what their, their CSP has dynamic. Okay.
Yeah. So they have nonsense, the strict dynamics. So it's fine to add stuff with like a script
gadget that then adds a script to the page. Wow, dude, that's, that's awesome. And these,
these gadgets are, are so complex and actually I've got a, a situation. I don't know. Um,
I don't know. Did, did Monke reach out to you recently with a, uh, a CSP bypass that he needs,
uh, on a very highly, uh, CSP environment or no?
I don't think so. Okay. Cause I've been banging my head up against this for a little. So after this
episode, I, you know, I'm gonna, I'm gonna show that to you and see if we can get it, get a bypass.
But, um, yeah. Okay. So that, that makes a lot of sense. You you're, let me just, but it also like,
it also, it takes a lot of time. So it's not really something you can do if you're just like
skimming through programs, like jumping around, like finding one of these. So when I, I found some of my
own where I could just like inject this, like one click stuff and I got it through dome purify.
Then I know that if I can just find like one, because you could have like an injection that
is like full, but then you can also have these ones that are actually sanitized. But if you can still,
so those are like easier to find because they make that mistake more often than just the getting by.
So, so, so, so with these, like, how do we identify these? Are you, are you literally just
like crepping through the source code, looking for any sort of like, um, dot, whatever, like clearly
a class CSS selector, like an ID CSS selector that's put into place and, and then trying to figure out if
they're binding any functions to these sort of classes existing, or is it just reading through the
whole thing and like, well, how are you identifying these? Is there some trick to this or?
No, I've been doing it like, uh, all the different ways, like, uh, putting a break point at the
beginning of the, the JavaScript just to see if it adds something. Uh, but then also just like looking
at all the places where it's actually using like CSS selectors to get elements, uh, and to see if, and
for, for, for, yeah, usually they have some sort of like main functionality that's kind of like kickstarts,
uh, whatever all the other JS on the page is gonna do. And you can kind of see there if they're like
trying to, uh, initialize, uh, this, this reminds me of a bug that I found that is, of course, hacker one,
my two weeks is up right now in the middle of this pod. So now I've got to like,
It's always on Monday.
I don't know. Somehow it's always in the middle of the pod when I'm trying to like get into my bugs to
like talk about something. But the only thing I've ever found that is remotely similar to this is
essentially what you just mentioned, which was, um, hijacking selectors, um, for, for your, your
purposes. So I remember in this one scenario, I believe it was a WAF based scenario, um, where I, I
could only get through like on click or something like that. And it was, and it was on an element
that you couldn't click on or something. And I was able to like name it as specific ID and add a
specific ID to the element. And then later down it would say like, click this ID, like this ID or whatever
dot click. And it would hijack it and pop the XSS. And I was like, I am a legend, you know, like, and then,
you know, Johan rolls up in here with like this 16 step chain. Um, no, so just, just to, just to summarize
this for the listeners as well. Um, like I mentioned before, this is a really great example of how a
hacker adapts in a, in a different environment, right? Um, most of us, like I mentioned before,
are not really exposed to hyper CSP environments. And as we continue to, um, move that direction in
the industry where CSP becomes more widely accepted and more, um, you know, just as time passes and it,
it gets a part of everything as default, um, we're going to have to adapt in this way. And so it's
really helpful for us to look at examples like Johan and how he's adapted already over time to, um,
bypass these, because we're going to be doing a lot of gadget searching like this in the future.
So I'm going to go ahead and start studying up on, on all this and try to be ready for that shift in
industry. And I think it's really, um, a great thing for the community that a lot of your reports,
are, are, are disclosed in, in, on GitLab. And then, you know, you're doing interviews like this,
where we can kind of talk through the mentality, uh, because otherwise trying to get good examples on
how to find these gadgets and that sort of thing would be, would be really tricky.
Frick guys, every time I hear Johan talk about that sort of thing, it just blows my mind. I, I love it.
I love it. All right, let's change gears a little bit. We're going to, this next clip is from episode
80. Uh, this was Pwn2Own versus H1 life hacking event with Syn Synology, Synna. Um, so really,
really appreciate this episode. It was a long one. We covered a lot of stuff. We tried to pare it down
best we could. Um, but we're, what we discussed here was how exactly to get a debugger attached to
enterprise software and IOT devices and how pivotal that is to being able to do dynamic analysis. And I was
sort of admitting on that, on the, in the clip that, you know, that's not something that I've done. A lot
of what I've done as far as enterprise software and even IOT device reversing goes is just been,
um, you know, looking at the code and then trying stuff. But after talking to him about it, uh, seeing
this sort of thing, uh, in action, you know, seeing a debugger attached, man, it's, it's freaking good.
So he's got some great tips on how to get it done. Let's jump to those now.
So, you know, I want to, I want to move over to a topic that you sort of mentioned before,
and then, uh, something you also have in the notes saying that a debugger is super important to you.
Um, and I have a little confession to make here on the pod. I have not set up a debugger on like an
active debugger on a, on a target that I've worked on before. I've done so much, uh, you know, white box,
um, you know, source code review, that sort of thing, but it's always been me looking at the code,
me crafting an exploit, me sending it in and then being like, you know, why the frick isn't this
working, you know, and not having any introspection into it. And when I think about the luxury of having
a debugger, I'm like, oh man, that would make this process so much easier. Um, so for, for those of us
that haven't actually had, um, that experience before, can you talk a little bit about what that
adds to you and then how, uh, just at a high level, how, how difficult it is to set it up in various
environments like a Java environment or a, or a .NET environment?
Uh, that's actually a really good question. Even I was the same back in the day. I, I would like
look at the source code if it was like a web app and I'd be like, okay, this is a function. It's
checking to like input arguments from the query string or maybe the post body or whatever, or maybe
a header. I can see it clearly in this code. And then it's, it's, I don't know, passing it to like
a SQL query without sanitization. Okay. I understand it. I just need to hit the sample with my
rep suite or whatever, uh, provide these arguments and then I will hit it. Right.
And most of the times that works, right? Yeah. Um, but at a certain point in time, you, you, you come
across applications which are far more complicated. Uh, and then, um, for some reason you're trying to
send those parameters or whatever, either it's a TC, it's a TCP server, which has been written in
CC plus plus that you need GDB to attach to is a compiled binary, or it's a .NET target, which you
need to attach Dnspy to it, or it's like a Java target, which you need to attach like its own
debugger to it. Either it's a, I don't know, like a unit can use like JetBrains products or any kind of
other product you want to use to, to debug, to debug it. And then for some reason you're not
hitting that end point. Uh, the web suite is, I don't know, you're giving like a 404 or an unauthorized
or whatever. If you're doing only source code review and it's like a huge application, you might think,
why doesn't it work? Should I move on? Maybe the code is dead or whatever, or maybe something,
you don't know that thing, right? Somebody's inside my brain. You don't know the thing.
That's exactly what I say in my brain. I'm like, why is this working? I could see the source code.
Like, why? Exactly.
You say like, I'm seeing it, like either the compiler, disassembler, whatever,
I'm seeing it. Like, why isn't it being hit? But when you attach a debugger to that, like,
to that target, say like a Java target, you like use like, uh, many debuggers for Java, but like,
I usually use like JetBrains product for Java targets. You, you attach to it and then you understand,
okay, there is a filter or an interceptor or a middleware, which is, which is like way, way,
way before this route gets called. And that's looking for certain header, but I'm not sending it.
And that's why, for example, I'm not reaching the sync to reaching this function or whatever that
helps. Or sometimes you want to bypass mitigations, uh, and you want to keep testing for it or, or
fuzz the behavior or whatever. When you attach a debugger, you can, in most of these, in most of
these, uh, debuggers, you can start, uh, writing expressions, right? You can write Java code or dot
net code, uh, or like peek into the memory or change stuff and then call a function again and again and
again. Uh, and then that kind of like speeds up your analysis and your understanding.
I'd say so. Uh, exactly. Uh, and, uh, which is, which is perfect. I've, I've actually started with
debuggers, uh, like with like GDB, I was just mostly debugging like low level stuff, just like
peek into the memory, not, no extension, no Jeff, no point, uh, point DBG or point back, whatever you
want to call it, no wind DBG or wind back, whatever. Uh, none of those. I was just like using like pure,
like classic GDB for embedded exploitation, most of that. And then I've, and then I was just,
as I was like doing more like web app and like.net job, I was like setting up PHP debuggers,
dot net debuggers, Java debuggers and all of that. And then setting up a debugger helps a lot. It is
painful sometimes. And that, and people choose to move on. I have, I have chose to move on sometimes,
but as I grew, I've learned to don't move on and whatever it takes, just have it set up. I kid you
not, uh, in some of the point to own targets that we worked on, there were some like exotic architectures
that they don't have, they don't have, it's called an RTOS, like a real time operating system. So it's
not like a Linux or whatever that you can get a shell and then you, you can upload a debugger or
whatever, right. It's a real time operating system. And you need to like, when you want to debug stuff,
you gotta like open up the device and like attack some, attack some sort of like a physical device
and all of that. And just like, it's pretty, pretty painful. And then when you go through that, you're
like, okay, that takes like 10 hours. How long is it going to take me to like set up this Java
debugger? Okay. One hour, two hours, let's, let's just do it. Right. It works. So, so, okay. I'm sold.
I'm sold. You, you sold me on the debugger thing. That's great. So, so that, but the next thing is
kind of what I want to ask about is like, how does this work with various targets, right? Cause you're
attacking these IOT devices, you know, you don't have access to the firmware specifically, you know,
you don't necessarily have access to this, um, you know, Docker container of the operating system
or anything like that. Um, and you want to get one of these things set up. Uh, how do you, how do you
get that set up? And then also, you know, in, in a scenario where you're dealing with like a.net
application or whatever that has like, um, you know, its own Docker image or something like that.
Uh, how are you, how are you reaching into that Docker image and setting up this debugger,
um, versus like something in the, in the IOT world where you've got like a physical device that you don't
have an image for. Uh, yeah. Uh, okay. Uh, I think, uh, I think I understand the question. Uh, please,
please try to jump in if, if it wasn't the right answer or if it felt like this is not the answer
to your question. Uh, most of the time, I don't know if it's like a Java target, if it's on a Windows
or a Linux, uh, you need to understand how the job of Java process is being started. And then you can
like provide arguments to that, to that command that's starting the Java process. And then when you
provide arguments to it, you can, you can enable like Java debug wire protocol, like JDW or like
other stuff to, to enable debugging, which exposes a deep debugging service that you can connect to
with your debugger. Most debuggers allow remote debugging. So that's what Java. So, so for Java,
let me just, let me just echo this back to you so I can make sure that I understand it. Yeah. You
know, for Java, let's say we've got a Docker container. It spins up this Java app or whatever
with the jar file, you find whatever like dot sh file or whatever that's being run that
triggers that Java command, you know, Java dash jar, whatever, right. And then you, you modify that
file usually and, and you say, okay, um, now I'm going to turn on debugging and then maybe you got to
open the port in, in Docker or whatever. And then, and then you can connect to that debugging port, uh,
via your debugger and it will allow you to just jump exactly and control that, that flow of the application.
Yeah, exactly. Uh, yeah. Um, you got it right. You have this Docker image. You will try to get a shell on the
Docker image, modify it in some sort of a way to, to enable like some sort of arguments to the, to the,
to the, to the Java starter command or whatever, a bachelor script or whatever it is in order to
allow, to enable debugging. That's what Java usually that's the trick, right? There are some special
cases too, but usually that's the way to do it. Um, as far as I'm, my knowledge goes, um, can you hear me?
Right. Yes. Yeah, absolutely. So, so, so for, for like something like .NET, um, you know, I imagine it's a
little different. Are you like loading up a, a DLL or something like that or, or how are you addressing that?
Yeah. So with .NET you just like, uh, you have different kind of debuggers, uh, but like with, with the
INSPY, usually what happens is, is, uh, you use the INSPY to, the INSPY has like a debugger, debugger feature. You can, you can
attach to processes or launch a process. When you launch a process, you can start immediately
debugging from the program start. When you attach to a process, you attach to its current state,
whatever it is at the time that you're attaching to, um, attaching to it. And then you, you attach to it
and then you kind of start debugging. But sometimes when you start, start debugging that target process
in .NET, you start saying, okay, my break points are not even hit. So you need to do that up, the
optimization trick that I told you about, that you just place an INI file next to it with some sort of a
value. And then you just restart the process and then you attach it again. Um, there are some
special cases too, but these are the usual things that happen with, uh, IOT stuff like embedded stuff.
Most of, most of the times, if it's, if it's a device, which is like Linux space has like an operating
system or whatever, um, you, you want to like push GDB to the device. So you have like an aesthetically
compiled GDB clients or a GDB server. You push it to the device, you upload it in some sort of a way
where taking, uh, considering you already gained a shell on the device because with IOT stuff,
when you get the device first, you need to acquire an initial shell on the device.
Yeah. Um, so let me ask about that process really quickly. So, so, um, I also want to go back to the
.NET thing for a second, because I would like to ask about, um, remote debugging with .NET because in,
in the scenario that you, that you had, um, you know, we're, we're in the same environment. We can just
attach to the process or whatever, but if we're doing like, let's say we're running this .NET
application in like, uh, you know, a different environment, is there some way to connect from
like, uh, from like, uh, a remote context for that? As far as I know, this is, as far as my knowledge
goes, I don't know if it's possible to debug a .NET process remotely. With Java, it exposes a port
that you can connect to remotely. Uh, so basically it runs a listener, but with .NET, as far as I know,
the Inspire attaches to the process and uses Windows debugging APIs and MS Core Lib, which is
Microsoft, like Microsoft library for .NET, like CLR, the common language runtime. These are like .NET
specific technologies and engines and uses those to debug into that process, to attach to that process,
to debug it. Um, but I don't, I haven't heard about somebody debugging a .NET process remotely.
Yeah, that makes sense. Okay. So, so moving, moving to the IoT side then, when you're approaching this
hardware target for like, uh, an event or whatever, obviously you got to get this initial shell to get,
you know, your, your debugger set up and on it. Right. So, um, I feel like there's only two approaches to
this. There's like hardware hacking techniques, right? Where you've got your UART, you've got your JTAG,
you've got, um, you know, glitching related stuff, that sort of thing. Um, or you got to go black box
and you gotta, you know, you gotta try to pop it without actually, uh, you know, having the source
code or whatever. I guess there's one third option as well, which is like, if you can get your hand on
the firmware, then you can sort of be white box, but still not have a debugger. Um, what is your go-to
flow with that? And how do you address all of these three possibilities?
Yeah. Uh, that's a great question. Uh, so in order to like start researching like an
IOT device, uh, basically first you need to like get the device after you got the device,
you want to interface with the device, right? You want to get a shell on it, assuming it's a
Linux based system, not some sort of RTOS or whatever. And then you can use like some sort of
like a UART, JTAG, whatever to interface with the device. Once you do interface with the device,
if it has like some sort of a console, you try to like, usually after the console, you have,
you have unlimited shell, like you have like a root shell or whatever, and you want to buy,
you want to get around it. Basically what I'm, what I'm answering is the usual answer, right? It,
there can be, there can be different scenarios, special cases as well, which happen often. Uh, but,
um, in order to bypass that kind of like a console, either you get the password or you can get the
password or whatever. Sometimes the password has been public by someone else or whatever. It's like a,
maybe like a root one, two, three, or a vendor name or whatever. And then if you can't get around it,
then you can like use glitching. Sometimes glitching helps almost all the time glitching works. Glitching
is super powerful. If you master it, like the sky's the limit. And then you can like use like
glitching to get around that protected shell. Um, if you do, that's one way. Sometimes the firmware is
available on the vendor website. You can just get the firmware back to the firmware and install the
firmware on the device and just get the shell. That's it. Right. Sometimes it can happen.
Uh, sometimes you just gotta like YOLO it and then you're like, okay, I've, I've, I just take the chip
off and then just read the chip and then write to the chip back door, the firmware, whatever, repack it,
repack it, and then just put the, put the chip back. But you need to like, no disolder, like soldering,
soldering, like all that. Um, and sometimes the chip on the device is not like a, like a, like a,
like a simple normal flash chip or whatever. It's like an EMMC or a BGA, which you usually see them
in phones. So when you like the solder or like take it out, um, you, you need to know how to do reballing.
Yeah. Which, which is hard, man. It's hard.
Right. Exactly. You gotta have like steady hands and like do a clean job. Uh, sometimes there is some
sort of wiggle room for you to like mess up just a bit. You don't need to, you don't need to be perfect in
doing it, but sometimes it, which I've tried it actually for, for Ponto on 2024, uh, Ponto in Japan,
I had to, there, we were targeting these infotainment systems, uh, which are like
refotainment for cars. And then most of the times you couldn't actually find, like you had to like
disolder it. At least for me, like for a lot of them, I had to disolder them. And then, uh, the device
is so expensive. Like, I don't know, two grand, three grand, four grand, you can't just buy two or whatever.
Uh, so you need to like disolder it and you need to do no reballing to put the chip chip back and then
to, to, to use your shell or whatever to go on the device and start working on it. But the sky's the
limit, uh, as I said, sometimes, and then maybe, maybe, maybe sometimes even you don't need to make
it more difficult. Maybe sometimes black box, you can find a command injection in the application and
you just get it with shell. That's it. Right. All right. Next up, we've got crushing client side on
Any Scope with Matan Bear episode 81. Um, this is an amazing episode. There were so many pieces of
this. It was really hard to pare it down, but, uh, Matan is extremely talented at client side stuff.
And one of the biggest pieces of that, one of the biggest tools we use in that is DevTools. And,
uh, he really dropped some great insights on how to use breakpoints, log points, conditional breakpoints,
and just some, uh, some high skill stuff in this one. Um, so check this one out.
There are some tricks, like some very quick and dirty tricks that I like to use while, um,
testing with DevTools. So if I'm trying to, like, modify some piece of code in order to test something
or whatever, um, I usually don't want to start, um, setting up a match and replace rule for it.
And also don't want to, um, use the override feature because, um, it tends to be a little hard and
Yeah. It messes up. Yeah. That's been my experience as well.
Yeah. And it's like, it has a few issues because sometimes, um, you know, the integrity attribute.
Yeah. Um, yeah. So you can have on a script, you can have an integrity attribute.
Um, the checks, the checks are more the harsh of the script. You could also have that in like a CSP
or something. And if you change it, like change the actual file with, um, that tools override, then
it's gonna change the checksum of it. And that will misbehave because it's not gonna be valid
anymore. So what I do is I set a breakpoint and with dev tools, there's, there's actually a few
different types of breakpoints, which is interesting. There's the regular, like blue, um, breakpoint
that will just break whenever, um, it gets executed, but there's also, um, one that's orange, a conditional
breakpoint. And you can put just like a statement there or a piece of code, um, in the breakpoint,
when you sort of edit it and it will execute that code. If that code returns to, then it's gonna
break there. If it returns false, it's not gonna break. So if I want to like override something for
like a quick check or something, I, I set like a break point there and I edit it and I just write
out the code that I want to inject there and I do like a semicolon and the right false at the end.
So it doesn't use it as a breakpoint and it's super quick. It's like, wow, what the heck? That's a
genius technique. What the heck? Why did you tell me about this before dude?
Because I wanted to save your reaction for the post with farming content.
Dude, that is nuts. I thought, okay. So I was reading over this and I was like, oh yeah,
you know, conditional breakpoints. That's something that people need to know about.
We should definitely talk about that. Of course, I'm just using it like a normal human
and just setting conditional breakpoints. Yeah. Not like a crazy person would.
And you're like actually writing scripts inside conditional breakpoints. Wow. That's,
that's a super cool tip. You never have to leave like your environment and it's way like,
it removes friction. Like you talked about, I think maybe last week or something on the pod,
um, about removing friction when you're testing and it's super valuable for that.
Wow. That's nuts. That is so exciting actually, because you know, what I'm often doing is I'm,
um, I'm using match and replace, uh, to actually overwrite parts of the JavaScript. Right. And,
and so like what I'm thinking of a target that I, that I'm working on, um, right now. And I,
I ha there's a JavaScript function that says like, oh, is this feature turned on?
And I'm like, okay, well, what, what if you just always returned to true? You know,
that would be really helpful. Then every feature would be turned on instead of me having to like,
you know, match and replace this whole long list of feature flags. So I do that, but then you're
absolutely right. You know, sometimes there's integrity checks and that sort of thing.
For that specific use case, I would still use a match and replace because, um, the log points and
stuff, or the, I'm getting ahead of myself, the conditional breakpoints are only executed. Um,
if the dev tools is open, it's the same with them, all the lights and stuff. So if you just want to
test the app, like the features and stuff, um, match and replace is the way to go. But if you're
looking at, uh, at the JavaScript and you want to quickly change some something, it's, it's way quicker
and way easier to do it with, by misusing a conditional breakpoint. Very cool. Very cool. But I,
I think it's also important to shout out the, the conditional breakpoint, um, actual functionality,
Matan, which is that you can do a conditional breakpoint, right? You can write a JavaScript
statement, which will, if it evaluates to true, it will trigger. And if it doesn't, then it will not
trigger. So this is really helpful. Yeah, definitely. What, what I sometimes do with it,
um, when I'm trying to look at like some message listener, um, I put like a breakpoint on the
message listener and sometimes, um, like usually, um, you would get a ton of different, uh, messages
from like browser extensions or from like the regular app and stuff. So I just like, um, put a
conditional breakpoint and I will do like E or whatever the name of the event, uh, the, uh,
list dot like ASDF or something. And then only if it has, um, a to the, uh, ASDF property, it will
break. So, and then in all of my testing, uh, messages and like ASDF. And then you don't have
to keep pressing that like little play button, play button, play button over and over again.
That's great, man. Yeah. That definitely reduces friction and increases the efficiency of your testing,
which like, like we said before, I mean, it just has very, it has cascading effects. You know,
it continues. You think it's just a little small thing. I just got to press, you know,
play a couple of times here, but it allows your brain to not think about that anymore.
Yeah. And even more importantly, um, you will feel less resistance before you do the accent. So
if I'm like trying to test something and I know that I'm gonna, um, have to press like
forward 10 times, I'm gonna be less likely to, um, to actually do it. So that's a great point.
It's not only in the moment. It's also, it also affects like the way you think about what you will
do. Yeah. So that's, that's a great point because it allows you to go further in your testing because
you're not getting tired as quickly. Like, oh, okay. You know, I've already tried three things.
I'm not gonna like go through this flow, you know, five more times. Uh, I'm just gonna skip it. Versus
if, if you just have lower friction, you still are able to just go, go, go. Um, so that that's,
that's a great, we have a lot of different points to go through here. So we do, we gotta keep moving.
I'm sorry. What's the next one? Hit me. So I'm gonna go through the next one very quickly. Um,
we mentioned regular breakpoints and conditional breakpoints. There's also what's called log points.
So you put in some code there and it passes that code. Like it's, um, a list of arguments to console.log.
So if you put like a string and then a comma and some variable, it will log, um, the string and the
variable and actually using commas in, uh, in console.log and stuff is very useful. And what I
usually do with this sort of, um, breakpoint, I have a very specific use case for it. Um, a lot of
the time the app, um, the web app is gonna have some function that's like a conditional log of
something or something. So they will have some like logging library. Um, and they will check,
like, sometimes they do it with, um, local storage or whatever. They will check if debug mode is
enabled. So instead of going in and like, um, checking how they're checking whether debug is
enabled and then overriding it or something, I just set a log point in the function that logs stuff.
Um, and that log point will just log the arguments of the function. So if they have like a, a function
called debug or whatever, that's checking whether debug mode is enabled. And if it is, it's gonna log
something, my log point is just gonna log it anyways. So then you get a bit more visibility into what's
going on.
Dude. I did not know this existed. And let me tell you. So it might be a new feature because I didn't
know about it too until recently.
Yeah. So, so I, I've like, I'm looking at this and what's odd about this. So, so here's how you do this
guys, um, in the dev tools, you know, they, they've got the little line line, you know, row or whatever on
the left-hand side, I think it's called the gutter technically, but, and you click over there and it
sets a break point, right? Well, don't, don't left click right click instead. And you'll see, add log
point. Here's what you can right click. Wait, what are you, what have you been doing? Um, I've been
clicking on it, then clicking, um, on the side panel, edit condition, and then you can change the, um,
Oh, and then the log point. Right click is way more useful. Oh, very interesting. So the reason I never
knew that this existed is what I always do is I, I click to add the break point, right? And then I
right click on the break point to hit edit break point and then set conditional break point. But
actually if you right click after break points already set, it won't show you the option for a, a log
point. It'll only show you the option for break point. So instead of left clicking the first time,
Don't you have a little drop down there? I do. I do. But, um, up at the top. Yeah, I do have that,
but I, I did, I never saw that before. So what I'm going to do now though, is instead of right
clicking on our left click, I'm going to right click and hit add log point. And that will just add
the log point on there. Wow. I did not even, it's hard to teach me stuff about dev tools because I
kind of live there, but yeah, I just learned a new trick. That's crazy, man. This is, this is, um,
this is super helpful. So we can just do, and then you said these, this input here is just
essentially console.log at that specific point in the code. Yeah. And it, it's not just console.log
for a specific object. It like passes a list of objects. So you can put like commas there or
something. Oh, that's great. Um, that is helpful. That is super helpful. Uh, and then, then I don't
have to like, I don't have to do the break point and then go to console and then type console.log.
That's super helpful, man. Wow. Um, very cool. All right, guys, not going to lie. This next episode,
episode 86, the X correlation between Franz and RCE is one of the craziest episodes we've had this year.
Unfortunately, there were a little bit of production issues with the mic and the audio quality is not
super great, but the content is super great. So we still snagged a little segment, uh, feel free to
jump through it if you need to. I know that the audio isn't, isn't, uh, fantastic, but, um, Franz's
research here on, uh, the X correlation ID headers or X request ID headers, uh, is just absolutely amazing.
And the way that, that, uh, Franz and, uh, Matthias were able to turn this into so many RCEs and in
critical vulnerabilities and logging infrastructure is just really inspirational. So, um, if you,
this clip speaks for itself, let's, let's go.
From a, you know, blank perspective, not knowing the company that you're targeting,
you need to like, figure it out what type of, uh, like, Heather it's actually being used for the
correlation. Okay. And one, one way to look at it is looking at the responses. They might serve you a
unique correlation ID just because you made a request. Uh, another one is like, you can see it
in the, in the access control headers. So you can see like, okay, we allow these certain headers and
one of them being the, the, or in this case transaction ID, but they could be named.
And that's typically in those scenarios where you're dealing with a cross-ordinary API.
Oh yeah, absolutely. Yeah. Uh, and so, so these access allow headers are perfect for like
understanding what type of headers do they actually need to work from the front-end side or client
side? That's solid. Yeah. Yeah. Uh, another one is like, this is the perfect thing. Like as soon
as you see reflection, and especially with, when you don't have like a validated format, uh, in this
case, like whatever, uh, this is like gold. Okay. Uh, and it doesn't necessarily mean that you will hit
gold on every single request. It means that this will follow at some, you know, if you find some
obscure, you're, you're doing a lot of payment things. Yeah. Yeah. Oh yeah. This is, this is the place,
because there will be SSH keys signing credit cards and there it's, it's kind of. I've definitely seen
this sort of thing before and I'm not sure if we're going to release this on audio, whether we're just
going to do it on YouTube since there's visual component. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But, um, the service
transaction ID, uh, that he has included here on the request side, right. As a, as an HTTP header is
also being reflected in the response with the exact text. So there's no UID validation. There's nothing like
that. Exactly. And this gives you a lot of flexibility. Absolutely. Yeah. Absolutely.
And this, this, this tells me that this has gone, you know, in the backend and behaved as this is our
request ID and we will keep this request ID and we'll also reflect it back to you. Um, yeah.
I know. Shit. I've seen this. I've seen this many times. Of course. Yeah. Of course. Yeah. Now what?
So what I did is I start Fuzz. I removed the existing one and then I just put in, you know, a lot of
shit characters, but we don't know where we're going to end up. Right. We don't know what context.
We could be in SQL. We could be in file system. We could be in, uh, you know, a command. We could be
in, you know, whatever. We don't know, um, event, uh, Jason, whatever. So we need multiple tactics.
We need to figure out, be smart when the fussy in the fussy so we can figure out some parts at least.
Uh, and one, one way is trigger errors. Basically like you put in a lot of, you know, crazy characters all over
the place. Uh, and then, uh, are you just doing like an ASCII fuzz list? Like I have like all of the
ASCII characters URL encoded and then I'll apply like a URL decoder. Or I do, I, yeah, basically do these.
Do you literally just type the fuzz? No, no, no. I do. I do like a single quote, double quote, percentage
side, like all of these things where if that one, like a percentage side, for example, if that one
triggers an error, it could be two things. It could be like screen def or it could be a URL. Yeah.
Yeah. Those, those are basically, and if, for example, if a person breaks, it could be an XML context.
There could be also URL. Um, and similar things with like the dollar sign, parentheses or, or curly
braces, then, then, then you're in the goal. This is, this is one of the takeaways for me from this
event, just from some of the life hacks that we've got in Vegas was like, I need to do more
fuzzing like this and identification of what data is being passed through web context. Because there are a
couple of freaking bugs. Like this is time where they were just literally straight up back to
command injection. And I was like, oh, no, figure out the context is like, what's it? It's like
struggling or true. So what I tend to do is I tend to put this in the request and then I go on and do
manual testing about, you know, API paths. I always make sure that we're passive inside, you know, keeping
it there. That's why you had it in the match and replace. Yes. Okay. Great. So then, then I can, this can
happen. So I can, I can work for an hour or two hours or whatever. And then I go back and like,
I had a 500. What, what, what is the 500? Why did that happen? Why are you doing this to me, man?
This is, this is, of course, this is what you guys do. Of course. And then this is the fun part.
Because there might be additional, like logging specific to some of these edit points.
Yeah. I mean, I get excited about this because like, I have, I have not, you know, made this. I don't,
like this is, this is, this is, we talked about before, uh, about like, I'm talking about things
that I got bored with. So then I present it. Yeah. But the funny part is that like, you can talk
about, I I'm leaving the crumbs, but this is like, fucking huge. This is a fucking pie. I'm leaving.
This is. Yeah. Yeah. Uh, so it would actually be interesting. I'm, I'm going to continue, but it'd be
interesting also to have sort of like an, um, I'm thinking like an authorized sort of approach here
where you have it auto repeating every one of the requests. You differentiate them.
A differential between the status codes. Then you know that that was caused by.
Absolutely. I agree. Really cool. Uh, absolutely. Uh, and like, of course there's going to be false
positives. One of them like GCP, for example, uh, not all over the place, I guess, but most of the time
on Google platform or cloud platform, they actually validate what you send in and just, just the pattern
and making sure that it's like a UUID. Strong regex matching, man. It, it solves a lot of problems.
Yeah, for sure. Uh, another one is like, I've seen this a lot, like they actually made a border.
So the request ID is created on the first, you know, load balance or whatever. And then internally
you can, it can be, you know, sent over and stuff, but on the first kind of, you know, entry points,
no. Uh, so that is also common. Uh, those are kind of false positives. Well, but that's the
interesting part. So let's say you have, uh, as I showed you here, like you have a bunch and then
that one says no, right. And then that is still interesting because then you know that there's
another system not allowing that thing to be happening. So it's still, it's still, these are
still like super interesting. Yeah. Okay. We had no idea what we were doing at first. It was just
breaking and we were like, where are we? We're probably in the path or whatever.
Um, but then we kind of, you know, let's, let's, let's just go through what we found.
Okay. Because these are fun. Let's get to it.
Okay. First, path traverse, arbitrary fire.
Oh no. And this one, I loved. So yeah.
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
Continue. Go ahead.
So the whole idea here, there was, uh, if you sent request ID, one, two, three, four,
four, blah, blah, blah. It would write it to trace data in the temp file.
Important part. It would contain itself. So the request ID was also the file path also
inside the JSON that was written. Okay. So you've got, you've got control of the path and some of the
content. Exactly. It was the same. It was the same. Yeah.
It's the request. Yeah. Or like it was a bunch of metrics in it, but the request ID that you sent in
also. But path reverse basically wrote, if you did dot dot, like temp data dot slash and then back to
temp data, it would, it would write the path traverse obviously. It just took the value and wrote it.
And did you just reinforce this or, um, or did you have access to errors?
Errors. Okay.
We had access to errors.
Okay. So what we could do is like, we could go down outside of the temp folder into the web folder,
put the PHP code as the file. 100% fine. It would then write to, uh, trace data in TMP,
do the pass traverse, uh, which basically meant that inside this PHP file, you would have the pass traverse,
but you would have the PHP code meaning when you went to this actual URL with the tags, you actually
got it. You've got to be kidding me. It's amazing.
This is, I can't believe they're dumping everything into temp like that. Like, are they,
they have a worker. No.
Like a race condition or something?
Yeah. They, they, they have like workers that dump this data into the temp and then they have
something picking it up, uh, from the temp folder. Ah, like a batch.
Like a batch. Okay.
So they, so the, the script itself doesn't need to connect to a login thing. They just need to dump a
file in the text. Okay.
Yeah. So that's why. So, uh, you have to read this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Exactly. It's like, it's perfect.
Another thing we found was a header injection. Okay.
Which is basically you, we provide, they will URL the code the header when they actually did something
with it. So we had like a client side request, added our request ID. It went into an API proxy.
We injected a header there because the URL, the code to the header and then the backend service
basically. So in this case, we're supposed to see account one, two, three, and just because the
request ID was above, uh, it will always take the first header with that name to get two of them.
So then you can inject another account and then you're getting their data. That's nuts.
Did you try like, uh, request splitting there? I guess, uh, it's kind of like response splitting,
but did you try like smuggling in another request? Cause I feel like you could almost do
DC. You can absolutely do DC. Uh, but no, because you just got, I mean, you got, I mean,
I'll buy that. So yeah, exactly. But you're a hundred percent right. The, the, the thing we could,
yeah, we could probably read this. Go for it. Seriously.
You'll get that target afterwards. Absolutely. Yeah.
Another one was, uh, Java. So, uh, Suresh Dalili made, uh, one, yeah, Suresh made a
awesome tweet back in like, like four years ago. And basically he says that like, if you have 010d,
in Java, sometimes that will actually turn into, you know, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0,
0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0, 0
That's insane. Yeah. Alrighty, y'all. Maybe I'm a little biased, but this next clip, Hacker Wife Mariah Gardner on Bug Bounty Mentality and Relationships, episode 87, I think it's pretty great. Maybe it's because it's Mariah, I don't know. But I kind of, I picked this one. I'm not gonna lie, I picked this one because I think it's amazing that Mariah, after seven years of marriage, has absorbed so much information about hacking that she will come on a podcast and talk about it in front of thousands and thousands
of people. And this was one of our top episodes of this year. Mariah seemed to be pretty popular with the crowd. So I appreciate all y'all's support. And I hope you enjoy this segment of my sweet wife trying to answer technical questions about Bug Bounty.
I think you'll do great. I think you'll do great. So let's go ahead and start it out. First question, what are the two primary HTTP proxy softwares?
Oh my gosh. Okay. HTTP proxy softwares, so Burp and Kaido.
Burp and Kaido. That's right. Correct. Ding, ding, ding. One point Mariah.
Easy. That's not even a technical question.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. They're coming. Don't worry. Don't worry. Um, hmm. I'm not gonna go down the list in order. Uh, what are the happy bug bounty report states? Like what, what are the on HackerOne?
Is HAPPY an acronym?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, it's not an acronym. What, what are the, what are the states of a report on HackerOne that, uh,
like triage? Is that what you're talking about? Yeah.
Triage is one. What, what, what are some of the other ones? Do you know any of the other ones?
Triage only. Uh, I got a dupe.
That's not a happy state. That's not a happy one. Just that good ones.
Yeah. Can you give me any?
Triage and paid.
Paid is not a state. Okay.
So triage.
Resolved is the state.
Resolved. There you go. Very nice, Mariah. Um, the, the other one is pending program review.
That's like the program needs to go. So it's been triaged by the company and by HackerOne.
And then the company needs to go in and review it pending program review. Right.
I was trying to be more like program agnostic.
Oh, okay. Sure.
HackerOne's not the only one that like triages.
That's true. That's true. Yeah. Right.
Um, okay. So what about the sad bug bounty states? You said one of them.
Dupe for sure.
Uh, what's the one, the not applicable one.
Hmm. Not applicable. Good. Is that applicable? Is that the right word?
Not applicable yet.
Oh.
N.A. Yep.
Um, out of scope.
Out of scope. Yep. Uh, that's not, that's not a state, but it is a, a, uh, you know, a delegation.
Did they ever just send you a thumbs down and go?
Yeah. There's one that starts with an I that, that I think, you know.
I'm sure I do.
I didn't hear you say it.
Inconceivable.
Inconceivable?
That's actually when it's critical.
Inconceivable.
Informative.
Yeah.
So like it sort of worked, but it doesn't really do anything.
Yeah, exactly.
Um, all right, let's see.
In your estimation, how much time does it normally take for a hacker to find a bug on a new scope?
For a hacker to find a bug.
I'm sure it depends.
It's very, it does.
It does.
Well, we'll try to generalize it.
We'll say for you and my estimation for you.
Okay.
It takes about a week to find 15 bugs.
A week to find 15 bugs?
Holy crap.
So you spend like three days not finding any bugs, whining about it.
And around day four, he finds like seven and he's like, oh, never mind.
And then the rest of the week, he just finds them steady from there.
Accurate.
Yeah.
I think, I think that first part with three days and no bugs and then the tidal wave,
I think that's very accurate.
Okay.
Um, I'm not sure if I've talked to you about this level of nuance, but let me ask you this.
So, you know, there's CVSS, right?
That's how we, we re-rate the vulnerabilities.
Oh, I know.
Yes.
Um, there's a metric in CVSS called privilege required.
Okay.
And the values for that metric are none, low and high.
Right.
So if you find a bug on, on an application that is self sign up, right?
You can go in and sign up.
Nobody has to approve anything, anything like that.
What is the value for the privilege required metric?
If you have to be, if you have to sign up, it should be low.
We have to be-
No!
Is it no privilege?
No, Mariah.
No!
You have committed the fatal error.
Um, it's none.
It's none.
Yeah.
Well, we like to think it's none.
For any of you program managers listening out there, this is not an endorsement.
Just because she says that doesn't mean I'm going to accept it.
You have to be a user.
That means it's listed up by definition.
Yeah.
But, but privilege required.
So the don't, don't give me that look.
Don't give me that look.
The, um, the attack starts from where, you know, you can define from where the attack starts.
So you can actually make a, wait, stop.
I can explain this totally fine.
Anyone else?
Um, when you are creating the steps to reproduce the, the attack, you can just say, okay,
first step is sign up for an account.
And since there's no inhibitor, you can just go through the steps that way.
You can just make up an email and.
Right.
Exactly.
And go through the, go through the process.
Sure, sure, sure.
Um, uh, and so it would start with privilege required none.
So just to check in general, if you are creating.
It's not a prerequisite.
Yeah, yeah.
But if you're creating a report in general, do you always get to decide from where this attack
starts?
Like, ignore the first half of this attack.
This isn't actually the attack.
No, no, no, no, no.
I mean, there's no preconditions is all I'm saying.
Like, it's a precondition related.
Wait, don't look at the first half, but like the attack actually starts here.
Is that like a normal?
No, no, no.
Denied.
Moving along.
You don't get to talk on this anymore.
Do not hold this against me, bug bounty community.
I'm just checking.
I'm trying my best here.
Okay.
I'm trying to understand.
Where is this light coming from?
It's that corner right there.
Is it that corner?
All right.
I'm going to adjust that real quick.
Yo, y'all exciting announcement real quick.
We are finally launching the CTBB podcast swag store.
Yeah, that's right.
The shirts that Joel and I have been wearing on the pod for the past couple months
will finally be available for y'all to purchase at ctbb.show slash swag.
We gave out quite a few of them at Defcon, but if you didn't get your hands on one
or maybe you want some more, then definitely check out the swag store.
Also, if you're a critical thinker on Discord, then check the Discord channel because you'll
have a discount code available for you there.
Or maybe this is a good opportunity for you to sign up and become a critical thinker if
you're not already because you'll get a great discount on the swag if you do so.
All right.
Cool.
I think that's a wrap.
Anything else I need to tell you about that?
I don't think so.
All right.
Cool.
Back to the pod.
Let's go.
Okay.
Next one.
We're getting technical now.
Okay.
What is an IDOR vulnerability?
An IDOR is an indirect object reference.
Mm, yeah.
IDOR is I like.
Oh, it's not object.
No.
Insecure direct object.
Oh, no.
No, that makes more sense though.
That was pretty close though.
An example.
Can I do an example?
Yeah, please give me an example.
An example of an IDOR is when you're on a site, right?
It's got really bad security.
So it's got lots of IDORs.
Yep.
And it'll say like in the URL or something, it can have like user equals and then like a number.
Yeah.
And then you can, if it's has poor security, you can just like change the number,
like 5 million to like 5 million and one.
And then you get a different user.
Perfect.
I can see that you've heard me explain this many times.
I know.
I like, you have a different IDOR that I really liked.
That wasn't just like a plain numbers one, like a plus one, plus one user integer one.
Yeah.
And you did one that was really cool.
That was, um, you figured out how they were creating user IDs based on timestamps.
Yeah.
That was a while ago.
But I really liked that one.
So it was based on-
I found one very similar at this last life hacking event actually.
It's timestamp from when they like created their account or something like that.
So timestamp from time of creation of account down to like the millisecond or something like
ridiculous.
Yeah.
And then you like figured out, you just guess that that's how they did it and you figured it out.
And it was like a really long string of numbers and, but it was an IDOR.
This is such a cute explanation of all this.
No, it's a good explanation.
No, it's very good.
You just described, uh, I believe is a UUID V1, um, sandwich attack or IDOR.
Um, so that's-
The sandwich attack.
That's what it was.
You know, I should have remembered.
Yeah.
Your specialty.
Okay.
Uh, let me see what else we got here.
Um, what, uh, I kind of already covered this, but what is CVSS?
Do you know what CVSS is?
Uh, let me see if I can-
You don't have to give me the acronym.
No, I kind of want to know the acronym because CVS is like the scoring system of whether or not
something is, you know, from informative to critical.
And I'm actually going to look it up.
I think it's common vulnerability scoring system.
Yeah, it is.
Scoring system.
So you get half, full half points for that.
Full half points.
Oh, thank you for your generosity.
You're welcome.
Um, so, all right, cool.
And then we've got it.
We've got another technical one and then we'll, oh, and then we'll do a non-technical one.
Um, what is an XSS?
XSS is cross-eye scripting.
Good.
Can you explain what it is?
Not as well as an eye door.
Eye door is my favorite.
Um, cross-eyed scripting is, so you've got like the page.
Right.
And you-
On the right track.
You've got a webpage.
You can sort of like paste your own code over that webpage.
So if you send someone a link, you can make them traverse through your malicious code
to the webpage and have like both like a pack.
It's like a package deal.
That, that is, that is somewhat accurate.
Yeah, exactly.
So you've got your malicious page.
Yeah.
And then, and then how does the package deal?
Well, they go through your link.
Okay.
Yes, exactly.
Exactly.
They go through the link on, on our attacker page and then it's still like,
then what does it do to their website?
Link.
Yes.
It's their website's link.
Yeah.
Instead of like badguy.rhino raider.com.
Yes.
It's still like the, the good link.
Oh my gosh.
I need to register that right now.
I need to put that DNS entry in.
Just before it airs.
You've got that.
Badguy.rhino raider.com.
That's perfect.
That is where I'm going to host all of my POCs from now on.
Yeah.
So then, so then you're right.
So they click our malicious link.
That was on our website.
And then what happens to their website?
Sucks up the bad website.
It sucks up the bad website.
And then they can only interact with the bad good website.
Yeah.
I mean, that's pretty accurate.
Because what you're doing is you're running code on their website, right?
Yeah.
Does that make, does that, is that what you meant to say?
But it's not, but it's not, you haven't actually changed the website.
That's right.
It's only in the victim's browser, right?
Other people aren't seeing it.
Yeah.
That's accurate.
Very good.
It's like a hat.
Very good, sweetheart.
You rocked it.
Okay.
Last one.
What is a good range for low, medium, high and crit bounties?
Good bounty range for each thing.
Yeah.
Low should be at least 8K.
What?
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
Well, you said I answered to like, not pro hacker on the other ones.
You're doing great.
I'm coming in pro hacker.
You are doing perfectly.
Okay.
Um, okay.
So we're talking about like, what is, what would I expect to see?
Not what is like, would be good.
Cause like, would be good.
It's probably higher in general.
Yes.
What is like maybe a, if you look at a program, you're like, oh, that's a pretty good bounty
table.
When I look at my programs, what I'm looking for is like at least 1K for lows.
1K for lows.
Okay.
Like out of the hundreds, I feel like it's pretty good.
Yeah.
Um, mediums around 5K.
I'm pretty sure I've heard you say.
Okay.
You're doing, you're doing great.
You're right on the money at this point.
Highs.
I guess I don't, it varies a lot for programs or programs that jump between a medium and a
high, right?
It does.
Yes.
So like 8K to 10K.
10K.
Yeah.
Sure.
10K can be some crits too.
So I'm sure there's like a, there are definitely programs that pay 10K crits.
And I, I personally kind of like a really wide range for crits.
Like 10K does feel like a crit payout to me, but also like 30K.
Would be awesome.
To a hundred K crit payouts.
Like some of these companies should definitely be paying a hundred K for.
Yeah.
Shopify has, I think like 25 or maybe it's 50 to 200 K for crits.
Whew.
Um, and.
So 50 is their lowest crit?
You may not ever get them to pay it because of the way that their vulnerability rating system
works.
But, um, the fact that it does exist and I have seen them pay it a couple of times.
So yeah.
Yeah.
That's a pretty big range.
So you like the bigger ranges on the crits?
You know, I do.
I'd rather be paid as a hacker, right?
I'd rather be paid out 10K for a crit than never be paid out 50K for a crit.
Yeah, absolutely.
Right.
Yeah.
That's just my personal.
That's, I agree.
I think that's a great, um, I think that's a great approach.
All right.
So that's all I had for my questions.
You did very well.
I'm going to give you a little round of applause here.
Those were like very, very gettable.
Yeah.
I think you did well.
All right.
Speaking of people I love, we've got my boy, Brandon, my mentee close to my heart.
Um, and he's going to be featured in this next clip, zero to LHE in nine months, featuring
grep me episode 91.
Um, and this one, we're talking a lot about attack vector ideation and how he really uses,
um, his checklist and his, uh, attack vector ideation to the checklist and then coming back
to it so that he's not getting distracted and running around there like an ADHD hacker.
Um, I think he's really got that methodology down pat.
And I think a lot of people, um, could really learn from how he approaches that.
So hope you guys enjoy this one.
I went to Vegas and I attended Ben the harm sex talk and he'd done a talk on SSRF.
And the talk was really good.
It had some workshops in there as well, all good stuff.
And not that the techniques or anything new to me, but I had the very, very harsh realization
of why aren't I looking for SSRF?
So talk was on SSRF.
And I sat there and I couldn't answer it.
And I felt a bit silly because I just thought there's no reason for me not to look for this.
I've experienced exploiting it in the past in a pen test context.
I just never bothered looking for it.
So I took that away and I was all right.
Okay.
Let's try and find some SSRF.
And then it's a three weeks solid.
I think it was.
I trained.
I escalated three SSRS into RCEs with Alex Chapman for three weeks.
Um, which was incredible and all headless browser exploitation.
Obviously that's Alex's jam.
Um, but yeah, it just occurred to me like if you have experience or some competitive edge around
whether it be a target or a wrong class, don't disregard that because that's knowledge and
experience you can very easily put to use with the right mindset when approaching a target.
That was my biggest takeaway.
This extends to industry as well, right?
Like if you, before you were a hacker have experience in whatever industry, the financing industry,
the construction industry, you know, the pharmaceutical industry, right?
There are almost certainly bug bounty programs out there that will utilize those terms or the
requirements of that, you know, field, the specific knowledge of that field, um, which is, is really,
really helpful for you and gives you a competitive edge.
Uh, that, that's something that, that me, you know, as somebody who's been forced to look at so many
targets because of live hacking events, like it became a little bit less important to me because
I'm like, well, you know, if, if, if hacker one or bug crowd or wherever is going to just point me at
these targets, I gotta be able to hack it.
But you know, when I'm in my off time, when I'm, when I'm not hacking off for these live hacking events,
you know, working on targets where I have.
You know, industry specific knowledge, uh, could be fun.
So I'm gonna, I'm gonna see, man, maybe, uh, maybe there's some real estate,
um, some real estate websites that I can go hack or something like that.
I can tell you right now, I have, I can list some off which are private, but you most definitely have
access to them.
There's a few, I know there's a few.
Huh, huh.
I hadn't, I hadn't really, I hadn't really thought about that.
Um, so, uh, to come back to what you said though, you mentioned a checklist and I know that you are very
structured and I don't know that we've actually talked about this, but I know that you're very
structured that you take really good notes.
Um, do you actually use a vuln class checklist or are you, is your checklist mostly like attack
vector ideation?
Then that goes on the checklist and then I'm checking those off one by one.
Yeah.
So when I approach a target where I've had previous experience, pen testing and have
like a base grounding on every, not every, but most phone classes, I use a threat model
approach on targets.
So I go on the application, sign up, unlock everything I possibly can, every single flow,
go through everything.
And then once I have that context as a normal user, I'll start going through my burp history
and playing around with the app.
And when I start peeling back the layers, I try and put down every single possible attack
vector, no matter how stupid it might sound.
Put down the attack vector, whether that be because the functionality is sketchy, whether
they're using a specific technology, whether the architecture lends itself to that, whatever it might
be. And my whole aim when I'm going through this process, when I first approach a target
is to come up with as many attack vectors as humanly possible.
So when I'm then hacking the target, I have a massive list of inspiration I can actually look at
and just get really creative with and tick off one by one.
And the idea is there is a living, breathing list document, which I can never finish because
the more familiar you get with something, the more ideas you should have.
That's my premise of why I do that and how I do it.
And for me personally, with the way I work and needing notes just to do any basic function of life
in general, it's been quite successful.
And you can pick back up on the target. You can look at this list and go, okay,
I didn't really try that last time, but it's on my list. And then you can start going down that route.
And I feel like if you are in a part-time capacity and your time is quite sporadic
and you can't just hit a target for two, three days solid, that very much lends itself towards that.
It's very, very useful.
Yeah. Wow. I think this, if I had to guess, obviously there's a lot of things going for you
over this past 10 months that have worked out well. But if I had to guess, I think this is probably the
number one thing that has served you well, is your dedication to attack vector ideation.
And it's actually, it's starting to click with me a little bit now, because I've heard you talk about
this time and time again. And I've even put it in some of these presentations that I've been doing
at DEF CON and just yesterday for the critical thinkers. The importance of attack vector ideation
and how pivotal that is, I think it's probably the most underrated skill in bug bounty. And it seems
like you have a good system for that. You start preloading this list, you get this massive list,
right? And then you start working on the items and you allow your creativity to trigger and you allow
yourself to go down different paths. And then when you get to a dead end, a lot of people that aren't
creating this massive list, they're just getting stuck. And they're saying, okay, well, I'm kind of,
you know, that didn't pan out. I don't know where to go next. But for you, you've got this document
where you say, all right, I don't know where to go next, back to the next item on the list. And then,
you know, you start from there. That's really powerful, dude.
Quick, quick, someone called the doctor because this next clip is of Dr. Bowman from the episode,
A Chat with Dr. Bowman, Life as a Hacker and a Doctor, episode 93. And our boy Jonathan dropped some
really helpful tips on the importance of having a process in place to get at that mobile API space.
Because there's a lot of friction to it sometimes. And a lot of hackers shy away from it because they
don't have a process, they haven't even thought about it, they're just opening up a can of worms.
And by the time they get to it, they want to be hacking, not setting up, you know, emulators and
stuff like that. So Jonathan gives you his flow for how exactly to get a iOS and Android app environment
set up to reduce that friction and making sure you're not missing out some of that juicy scope
that's there. So enjoy this one, y'all. So pivoting a little bit, you know, you mentioned before that one
of the early things you did earlier with Amazon was breaking apart the Android mobile app and kind
of diving into that a little bit, understanding how the APIs work to build this website or whatever
that was going to make you a millionaire. And I think you've done a pretty good job as well,
just looking, like talking to you at the Live Hack events and seeing the kind of bugs you're finding,
of looking at that peripheral scope of Android and iOS. And I think a lot of people go down the Android
out route, but not as many people go down the iOS route. So can you talk about your methodology with
iOS apps and how you're approaching that to attack these bigger organizations?
Yeah. So it's really important, I think, as a big bounty hunter to have an iPad that is jailbroken
and to have an Android that you can use to easily man in the middle. Because if it's too big of a
hassle to man in the middle all those apps, you don't do it, or you lose too much time. If it's super easy
to do, then you, for example, in the Live Hack event, you get the new scope, you see, okay, we've got six
apps there, we've got some websites. Okay, let's install all those apps right now on my iPad and on my
Android. Wait for five minutes and then come back and then just start trying to man in the middle
then and see what's traffic. So my methodology is I got an iPad that I jailbreak with Pilrein.
Pilrein is one of those jailbreak tools. And there's still an iPad available that you can jailbreak with
that tool that also updates to some of the latest iOS versions. I think it's the tablet, iPad 7. So have
a good look on the Pilrein website and see which models are still supported and if the model also
supports one of the latest iOS versions, because that's a problem. You need to have recent versions.
But the last time I checked was three, four months ago and it was still working well.
So that's the thing. And I got a spare Android phone pixel thing that I rooted, but also
with Android you can easily do use APK METM, APK Man in the Middle, it's on GitHub. So sometimes I just
catch the APK and then I install it. But I also think here it's important to
to have those devices separate from your own devices, because otherwise you end up with your personal
phones full with strange apps or keep up your own security. So have those different devices there
also really helps to open them up and update just all those apps and see which apps can be updated.
So you get some signal back from like, hey, there's something new.
This is really interesting. This APK MITM tool that you mentioned here. I hadn't actually seen this
before. I'd seen something similar with called Objection, which allows you to patch APKs and then
hook in via Frida scripts and stuff like that. But this actually seems like it's oriented specifically
more towards like getting rid of sir pinning and that sort of thing. And it just goes for that. So
it's like a one shot. Let me see if this works. If it does, great. And then if not, obviously,
I'm going to have to go down the custom route.
Yeah. And that's also sometimes I do. So then I go give it a try with Frida.
Yeah. And I'm going to have to go down the road. And I'm going to have to go down the road.
Yeah. And I'm going to have to go down the road.
And I'm going to have to go down the road.
And just give like them the MDN documentation, which is, I would say, the beginner friendly version of some RFC.
And then I tell them like to try to find the same information in the RFC that is more complete.
Right. So when you are learning HTTP, it's great to actually learn what is HTTP, what it's built on top of.
So TCP, TCP IP, how do you reach a domain? What is a host? What is an IP and everything?
And like go to the root fundamentals, because sometimes in those routes, there is like some big vulnerabilities.
Yeah. I mean, that's the kind of stuff you see with James Kettle all the time is he's, you know, sort of peeling back those layers and addressing the vulnerabilities at a lower level.
Yeah. I think that's definitely important.
I think it's difficult to give also resources like MDN or the RFC or whatever and say like, hey, these are the the, you know, source of truth for these things, because at the end of the day, like you said, you have to you have to go and find them, you know?
Exactly.
And and and so, yeah, absolutely. Reading the RFC and the MDN is a really great resource and something that we should do.
But there's also going to be, you know, those random little little forums out there, you know, with some do some old Linux geezer, you know, that knows that was there when this, you know, obscure protocol was created.
And you got to read that too. And so it's a lot of it's a lot of digging and a lot of like you said, you know, not necessarily being intimidated by these, these highly technical documents, because at the end of the day, this is what I always tell myself, you know, when I'm shaking in my boots in front of like, this, you know, very scary target is like, at the end of the day, somebody not that much smarter than me, probably, you know, wrote this whole thing. Right. Right. And you know, sure. There are there are some people that are
like, you know, mega genius people out there that are just, you know, leagues above us all. But I feel like given enough time, I can, I can, you know, compensate for the difference, you know, so, you know, remembering that these people aren't gods, you know, that this is not something beyond my, my, you know, ability to grasp, we just have to put in the time to get there.
Yeah.
So yeah, I think, and then also, you know, on the web fundamentals, just going back to the nuts and bolts of the web fundamentals, I think it's hard to know where to draw the line on those sort of things, right? Like, do I need to know what every single header does? You know, do I need to know what every single object on window, you know, in the JS engine of Google, you know, Chrome, Chromium, or whatever, do I need to know what all this means? And the answer is no, but
it wouldn't hurt, you know, like, you know, you can always spend more time going down that path. And that's one of the reasons why in this article, I, I outline or in the tweet thread, I outline this ratio of hacking to learning, where in the beginning, you're going to be spending, you know, 80% of your time or more on learning. And, and, but it's very important to get that, you know, 20%, 10% of the time actually hacking. So you know, where, where things are making a difference.
Yeah. And yeah, that's actually an interesting thing. Like on like trying to learn everything, like, where do you stop? Like, do you need every header? And I think like, you need to learn enough to be able to manipulate yourself the data and to be able to find back where you can learn the, for instance, like a specific header. You need to know where in the documentation you can find it back.
Like, you need to understand the overall concept, like the abstract of it. But what the day you are going to need to, to get, you know, your hands dirty. You need to find back where you, you, you, you learn this from. And in order to go even deeper in this specific technology.
All righty y'all that's a wrap on the 2024 roll up. Once again, shout out to the whole team that made it possible. Really appreciate it. It's been another year guys, another amazing year of critical thinking bug bounty podcast. And I'm excited for 2025. We got a lot of really cool stuff in store. I'm in a new office. As you can see, I got my workout in today. I'm ready to go. I'm about to submit my accountability reports to the full-time bug bounty hunters guild and get hacking. So, um, I'll see you out there in the program.
And that's a wrap on this episode of critical thinking. Thanks so much for listening. And if you want more critical thinking content, head over to ctbb.show slash discord, join the discord. There's lots of great conversations and chats going on over there. And if you want to support the show, there's the discord subscriber tiers, which give you access to masterclasses, AMAs, hack alongs, exclusive scripts, and an exclusive chat channel with us. We'll see you there.